the jury
in the alex jones defamation monetary
damages hearing
has awarded the families
45 million dollars
now
my understanding we've got a couple
articles there's punitive damages that
they're capped at two times the damage
is plus 750 000 which means alex jones
with compensatory damages is on the hook
for about 13 million dollars
i don't know how much that's going to
impact him he says that's that's that's
devastating but the crazy thing about
the story
is that the lawyer
asked the jury to destroy infowars
that's what he said he said destroy his
platform and i'm paraphrasing by the way
destroy his platform and make sure he
cannot rebuild it considering the rare
circumstance where a default ruling was
uh was uh presented jones never had a
jury trial the right to defend himself a
lot of people are saying this is
the whole thing was just an attempt to
destroy infowars because well alex jones
backed trump uses his platform to call
out
things like epstein and uh well that's
what they're saying it's about
i think it's fair to point out that alex
jones was wrong about what he said about
the sandy hook families and even his own
employees brought it up but this seems
to be
this is it's just absolutely it's a
crazy story so we'll talk about that and
then man we got to talk about this other
story too because it's just it's going
crazy in the media i talked about it at
4 pm this video out of vegas of an asian
store clerk at a smoke shop and uh some
guy jumps the counter and then the clerk
just knifes him and it looks like the
dude gets killed so we're going to talk
about all of that before we get started
my friends head over to timcast.com
and become a member if you'd like to
support our work and you'll get access
to our exclusive members only shows we
have uh tim cast irl podcast here on the
website monday through thursday at 11
p.m and then we also have a couple new
shows we have tales from the innovative
world and we're going to be launching
the rebooted cast castle which is kind
of behind the scenes and kind of just
fun us doing bits and uh it's going to
be it's going to be comedic of course
it's also pop culture crisis but you're
going to be a member for that they're
live monday through friday at 3 p.m so
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this news and more is tucker
max
what's up do you want to introduce
yourself for those who may not know who
you are
um
let's see i've written four new york
times bestsellers hope they serve beer
and hell is the famous one
but right now i'm pretty boring man i
live on a ranch
outside of austin with four kids and a
bunch of animals and
it's not boring on a day-to-day basis
but there's not like that funny stories
anymore it's not like oh my sheep did
something so funny today no they didn't
they're just cheap
people were chatting that you were like
the og guy of the blogosphere like
writing the stuff online and stuff true
back in the day yep right on well should
be thanks for coming we got a lot to
talk about so i'm glad you're here we
got hannah claire bremelo of course hi
i'm handler brimlo i'm a writer for
timcast.com
right on ian crossland over here hello
everyone good to see you good to meet um
let's keep it rolling we got chris poole
on the mic
hey what's up everyone i'm chris
all right we're gonna jump into that
first story these intros they should go
so much quicker these days all right
first story of the new york post alex
jones ordered to pay
45.2 million dollars in punitive damages
to sandy hook parents
let's get some important context here
real quick though
this is from abovethelaw.com
texas damages cap looms over alex jones
sandy hook defamation case they
basically lay it out the family wants
150 million they've awarded 45 but this
is where it's interesting they say here
others have pointed out the texas law
caps punitive damages
at twice the compensatory damage award
plus 750 000
moreover an exemplary damage award
requires a a an
unanimous a unanimous jury and only 10
of the 12 jurors agreed on the original
4.1 million compensatory award and if
the jury's original award was for
non-economic damages i.e to compensate
for the pain and suffering they may only
get the 750 thousand dollars in this
phase of the trial which is perhaps why
plaintiff's council tried to anchor the
jury at 150 million dollars in the first
place so it looks like all in all alex
jones will end up being on the hook for
about 13 million dollars they say texas
law prohibits telling the jury about the
cap so it may well return a massive
verdict which will then be reduced to
comply with the statute sending a signal
about jones's moral culpability but
allowing him to walk away with a slap on
the wrist in light of the company's
annual revenues in the neighborhood of
65 million
interesting thing here is
this is what uh me let me read here let
me read you what the lawyer said
quote
i ask that with your verdict you not
only take alex jones's platform that he
talks about away i ask that you make
sure that he can't rebuild the platform
that's what matters lawyer wesley ball
said that is punishment that is
deterrence um no that's execution
punishment is like we're going to make
you pay a lot of money and you're you're
going to learn to do this again what
he's talking about is completely
destroying
alex jones and everybody who works for
him so
that's it there it is this is what
everybody assumed this was all about
alex jones was uh was it was a default
judgment he wasn't allowed to defend
himself
they claim
and uh may be correct that he did not
comply with discovery alex jones claims
he did
it's a crazy story man what freaks me
out is that they just nuked his company
i mean i i think in my opinion jones
probably has a ton of cash because he's
been doing this for a long time
and i'd be willing to bet he hid a lot
of it why wouldn't he have but it looks
like they're just trying to destroy as
much of this company as possible
especially with 2024 coming up and trump
probably running again yeah i feel like
when you're as uh
financially successful as alex jones is
you know well in advance to set up
systems that will protect your money i
mean it's not like he's just sticking i
mean maybe he is but he's probably not
sticking the cash in the walls of his
house it's it's hidden under tax
shelters or in trust i mean not that i
could fault him or anyone else for doing
that why would you leave that much cash
vulnerable yeah
this is why people set up llcs for like
everything you ever noticed this for
people who are renting you may notice
you're paying rent to like your address
yeah like if you live at 123 fake street
you write a rent check to 123 fake
street llc and then you mail it in
because they want to limit the liability
you slip and fall in that house you sue
them they only got that one house in
that company but the people who own that
house they probably own 50 houses all
under their own llcs
or basic things you put your money in a
trust or a series of protected trusts or
blind trusts and then they're not
you when you co even if you get this
damage you can't exceed those trusts how
does how how would that work how does a
can you explain like how a trust would
work look just because i went to law
school i don't doesn't mean i don't know
anything about he's trying to distance
himself from his past
all right so so basically what a trust
is
is it's like it's almost imagine like a
corporation but it doesn't have a job to
do other than
uh be a vehicle for money so like i have
a trust in my uh we have a max family
trust and uh like most of my assets are
in the max family trust and my wife and
i are the executors of the trust and our
children other beneficiaries right so if
i were to like
get drunk and drive like an idiot and do
something stupid and hurt somebody and
they sue me and win they can't seize the
trust right they can only seize my
personal assets you know i have a few
cars whatever we have some nonsense but
there's not a whole lot you can take
um and it's a way of protecting assets
but from
basically from seizure
is there a risk
i mean yeah there's a few but not really
like
what's a risk a risk is my wife and i
could get divorced and the way we have
our trust set up is not like super well
situated for that that possibility and
then um
i mean if i live a long time there's
certain things i can't do with the
assets and that trust because they're in
a trust like i can't just
um uh i can't unilaterally decide i'm
gonna sell my property because my wife
is an executor as well so we both have
to decide what if it was a single like
single member transfer yeah well then it
depends on the trust right so like uh um
you can't just say okay my stuff's in a
trust and so no one can sue me like you
have there's certain legal structures
you have to go through like uh there's
so many different trusts blind trust
irrevocable trust spent thrift trusts it
just depends on what you're doing and
certain ones are protected from certain
legal liabilities some are not some are
protected from almost all it really just
depends it seems seems crazy though i
mean if that's the case then why
wouldn't alex jones just feel like he's
300 million dollars and trust like i
don't alex seems kind of crazy to me so
maybe he has or hasn't but most people i
know who have serious money like you get
into the eight figures and above then
you start protecting your assets and
things like that yeah yeah isn't there
some wasn't there i don't he's been in a
couple lawsuits related to sandy hook
and if i'm remembering correctly at one
point they were arguing that he
financially benefited off of the
suffering that he put like the family
and parents through by promoting
conspiracy theory or whatever as a claim
was so part of it is like
i remember
and i hate to quote this because i don't
have something in front of me to
reference but he um
he had they had wanted him to say
basically how much money he had made
during that time period because it
gained him he was well known but it was
one of the things that really uh gave
him a certain amount of notoriety and
that turned into financial benefit and
so therefore the argument would be and i
believe is that the family is actually
entitled to this profit because he made
it unfairly off of that right right
right so he in some ways he wants to
hide i'm not saying he does but like he
would want to hide his money
if that were true i'm not and i'm i
don't want to imply you're a financial
expert right but if you had a trust like
this could could it could there be like
a bank account with just cash in it you
could pull money out whenever you wanted
uh you can set up trust like that
totally yeah it's not that hard cause i
you know first when i heard that they
were getting going after him for four
million dollars i was like
alex jones is worth a lot he can easily
cover for i know he has at least two
kids right yeah yeah like i know he has
kids so like if he has any sense at all
or anyone around him has sense he has
trust set up probably individually for
the kids and then family trusts and
that's just one way to shelter money
there's a lot of other ways like you
know you you can panama
well yeah panama papers
no right i don't think he's operating at
that level like those tended to be
serious serious wealth um uh but you
there's plenty of places you can buy
property um dude just the state of texas
it's really hard to seize
bankruptcy is either seize assets in a
bankruptcy or from a legal judgment it's
very there's a lot of weird rules in
texas it's really hard this is why i see
this and they're like you know the
lawyer says make sure he can't rebuild
his company i'm like there's literally
nothing you can that's just posturing
i'm pretty sure i think you know some
people have claimed i i saw people
tweeting that uh they're filming a
documentary about it or whatever so
everything's really hammed up
but i'm like
even if alex jones
every last penny was taken from him some
random guy will walk up on the street
with a cell phone and film alex jones
ranting and it'll get millions of views
like just you can't take that away from
somebody no no social capital
invaluable or and just the ability that
he has whatever it may be i mean
the dude yells and people watch he's
already an established name i mean
people know him maybe if you had cut him
off years and years and years ago he
wouldn't have the kind of influence that
he has today but that's just really not
the case he's an established brand with
or without the company yeah and i i also
don't know if you could ever have cut
him off it's just like the kind of guy
he is he's he's a he's a he's a bull
charging through he's gonna
he was my understanding from people who
know him he was like that in high school
like that's just no really he used to
walk around the halls like yelling about
injustice of some whatever was the thing
at the time like yeah he i think he's
just one of those dudes
yeah they clearly don't like him so i
guess the the conspiracy theory as it
were
i i don't even know if you can call it a
theory or a conspiracy or whatever but
the idea is that
all of this is just to find the
vulnerability in infowars to
knock the whole thing down people have
left the company because of uh stuff
like this but i i think to be fair i
mean the dude defamed private
individuals this is what happens i mean
i remember when he was talking about
that i'm like dude what are you like
yeah there's things that you can make
the false flag claim on i don't think
this is it
this is not a hill to plant your flag
i guess you know what i guess the
argument they're making is that it was
working for him it was getting the
clicks and people were eating it up
there were people at the company telling
them to stop it wasn't worth it
now apparently there's like two more
defamation suits that are coming up yeah
from this from sandy hook families yeah
yeah i don't think it's gonna stop
i mean
look i i understand why the families
would be pissed you know or was that
some fall over yeah i totally just
kicked the truck throwing stuff
like i don't you know with kyle
rittenhouse i said this i'm like look
man
you know
i'm gonna give anybody the same uh uh
benefit of the doubt initially
i don't care if you're walter cronkite
if you're alex jones or whatever and
then you know i'll i'll when you say
something i'll fat check it that's all
that matters i'm not here to play these
these like who do i like who i don't
like games
but uh
yeah i don't know man
it's very clear that when you look at
i'll be careful how i say this
what people are saying about the court
case they don't care whether alex jones
is telling the truth whether he's lying
they just hate him they want him gone i
think he's like a mythical figure at
this point to a lot of people like he is
this symbol of all the horrible dark
corners of the internet that they're
afraid of and supposed to stay away from
and you know that may not be exactly who
alex is but they see it as sort of this
righteous victory over him because he is
a representation of a larger problem
with society
we got a cult let me pull this next
story in this saga daily mail says alex
jones is worth 270 million dollars
forensic accountant tells court true
worth of infowars founder i'm wondering
how much of this is just bluster
nonsense and they're saying this so they
can rip the you know just gut the
company because if you come out you say
he makes 800 000 a day which was like
one day or like two days or something
like that and then you claim he's worth
270 million you justify a massive hit
settlement right of course yeah right or
judgment yeah and then what if it turns
out he actually just doesn't have
anything i mean because i wouldn't be
surprised i guess he's divorced you know
he's an ex-wife or something like that
well like why would he keep 270 million
dollars in his bank account like well i
mean when some when a forensic
accountant says something is worth
something what they mean is the sale
price right like the the best market
price like i mean i just built a company
that's worth you know i don't know in
the top well actually i know exactly
what it's worth it's worth a lot
i'm not 270 million but like let's say
the company's worth i don't know 60
million right that means that's the sale
price we're not making 60 million a year
even top line right like it's 60 million
is the cost of the asset not what the
value it produces i'd i'd love to see
the financials i'd be shocked if he
someone said he's doing 60 million a
year now he's doing 180 pre-ban from
youtube and everything right
pre-platforming yeah so 60 would make
sense that's that's
that's 60 down they the the guy
apparently says that jones he says
records show that jones withdrew 62
million dollars for himself in 2021 when
default judgments were issued in
lawsuits against him they said he was
also funneling 11 000 a day into one of
his shell companies after he was alleged
to have defamed parents and victims of
sandy hook uh
i don't know man
they say uh apparently this guy is
saying that he rakes in about 70 million
dollars a year from infowars the
question is is that revenue or profit
it's got to be top line there's no way
that's profit they of course they're
going for the bigger numbers right of
course yeah so if 70 is the top line and
it depends how he structures his company
right
and most of that money is on supplements
right that's the presumption is that the
vast majority of that is supplement
sales
well so the question is how
now if he has some deal with an external
company he may only be taking 20 30
of that you know and so if it's i'm
gonna totally make up numbers if it's 50
million from supplement sale from
supplement sales his cut may only be 20
they brought this up in the trial they
asked they said that uh jones testified
his profit margin was 20 to 40 percent
makes sense and then they said in a text
message someone said a 70 profit and
he's like well that's not correct well
on the media company though maybe right
you run a media company you could run a
media company if you once you get some
scale
you can run that pretty profitably right
youtube's a crazy business man if you if
you spend money one time on a camera
right and then uh
start working yeah it can be 95 100
profit exactly right so so it depends he
could be 70
on his subscription model right yeah but
then the supplements it all depends i
doubt he's running a supplement company
he's probably got like partners in fact
i could probably figure it out i'm
pretty sure i'm pretty sure he has like
three companies right i could be wrong
and um like one of them does supplements
right and then he contracts them yeah
not other people who do the fulfillment
and everything i'm sure oh yeah like he
doesn't yeah he said that the stuff he
gets is the same stuff as like gnc in
whole foods exactly so so he's probably
making it's almost like an affiliate
deal right so he's probably making 20 on
that so like you look at a blended
average i could totally see it 25 30
on the whole company
70 on media you know when the news came
out i got a whole bunch of messages and
people tweeting at me being like alex
jones
200 to 800 000 per day people people
just sent me a message being like 160
million dollars just like
that dude is making an insane amount of
money but here's what i here's what i
think
if it's true my question is why wouldn't
he be spending it on
crazier things he has a nice house in
austin i know that it's expensive yeah
but i mean if you're making that much
money if he really took 62 million for
himself i mean there's a certain point
there's this tomb there's like you can
buy anything you know i mean he could
buy stuff or he can he we've already
said he has two children he can use it
to create generational wealth i mean
theoretically if he managed it correctly
they could really support generations to
come i'm just saying if it's true that
he made that much money where's the
shenanigans from alex jones you know
like we we put a 96-foot billboard of
our rooster roberto junior up right from
times square
and uh i'm i'm they banned james lindsay
so i'm like do i got to put up a james
lindsay
that's my thing now i think so so we're
gonna look into it because i'll totally
do it and we don't make nearly that much
money like we have enough to do these
these funny things with yeah but dude
that's not who alex is
and it's it's not who anybody is that's
the problem
yeah just me i guess there's some well
but where's elon they're just like i'm
going to buy every billboard in times
square you want the real answer on why
i'll tell you this is going to sound
super weird because like when i was when
i first started writing and i was like
the og on the internet and i was making
a little bit of money i i was just
making no money and like a lot to me was
like oh dude i made 10 grand this month
i'm like this is amazing like this is
more than i could ever spend that's what
i'm single and all you know
and so like i did like dumb ass [ __ ]
with my money too here's what happens
though man as you like i'm 46 now i was
26 when i started writing
as you
uh kind of
as you accrue wealth and power
and relationships the more
time you spend
doing dumb ass [ __ ] that draws attention
to yourself unless that's your business
model the uh the weaker it gets real
power wants to be invisible right and
real wealth wants to be unseen you know
like i i have a decent ranch in dripping
spring it's like 50 acres you know it's
fine right i one of my good friends has
a 350 acre ranch on barton creek it dude
switch was so expensive it's so nice and
if you saw the gate to it you would
think like it was some ranch shackle
like meth lab like around here like you
would never he doesn't want anyone to
know that he has this insane ranch with
like that's god i mean like he doesn't
want
i've found it's it's happened to me too
i've gotten more experience or more
conservative and less like oh let's do
cool ridiculous stuff just because as
i've gotten older and richer but it's
it's i get that
for sure but the question is like alex
jones is the culture warrior
yeah but that's see but what he cares
about
right like you know he looks pretty well
he i think what
he's one of those dudes i think he
actually believes he's doing the right
thing and he actually cares about truth
and he that dude's been ringing the
epstein belt for 15 years i agree which
is which is why i'm like if he actually
had this money wouldn't he be doing
substantially more
to push this stuff
see this is what i don't get and look it
really does come down to my my personal
world view versus what other people
think or see right it's just that simple
some people make 62 million dollars then
they're like better put that in my trust
for my kids or something like that yeah
me i'm like
you know we got michael malus luke
rudkowski up on billboards in times
square because they've been on this show
i respect them but i also think it's
important to have their presence be
expanded and i got to tell you the the
one one of the things i'm most excited
for was that we got luke ridkowski do
you know luke if we are changed i'm most
excited about getting him up in times
square on multiple billboards because
he's the guy who only a couple years ago
like walks up to donald donald rumsfeld
and starts questioning him one of the
few people who's gotten in the face of
these ceos and these big corporations
and i was like it's going to be the
funniest thing in the world when his
face is looking down on times square and
then this guy who actually had the balls
to go and question all these people is
going to be you know of significant
influence that's what i want to see it
doesn't it you know it benefits us
because it's a tim cast ad right of
course but i'm looking at this like
if we make enough money how can we have
a bigger impact on just making things
better dude that's awesome and i'm with
you i'm just gonna and i'm not arguing
this is right i'm just not i can't
because i've seen my i know a lot of
people who are pretty uh well known i've
seen i've come up with them and i've
seen the change in them
when people have something to lose right
like
they when someone's young and just
starting off or just got momentum and
you don't have anything to lose man it's
easy to do risky [ __ ] as you as you
have more have more people depending on
you as you accrue more most people
become more risk-averse and quite
frankly like when you start having a lot
of money and you're able to turn let's
call it a youthful idealism into reality
you start being an actual threat to
people in power oh yeah and then when
that lens turns on you and i've had it
turned on me not quite the way alex did
but it i've it's a lot dude it's a lot
and so like again not not saying he
should or shouldn't be a certain way i'm
just saying there's a reason that very
few people retain their idealism through
wealth and power
yeah you know i'm not trying to single
out alex on this one there's a ton of
wealthy people who speak up and then
seemingly don't do all that much but you
know there are a lot of people you'd
think should do more but do a lot i'm
not going to name anybody but they're
they're powerful individuals who fund
stuff
and then i just you know but my question
is
we've got cultural problems in this
country we've got cultural stagnation
cultural decay we've got a culture war
and that's because there is no
forward-facing no brazen no adventurous
no heroic no challenge no
figurative threat to the to you know no
one uh ruffling the feathers up or
anything like that i think we need to we
need to get more people to figuratively
throw a pie that's what i keep saying to
people i'm like dude what did you do you
made how much money did you make this
year and then you put it you bought what
like you did nothing with it mm-hmm so i
don't know man um
i would be happy living in a van down by
the river and everybody knows that's
true and that's why i'm like okay let's
put up these billboards and just keep
doing this this this crazy stuff
because i want to see things get better
i want i want to see a positive impact i
want to see positive cultural change i
don't see a benefit
or a point to just having 60 million
dollars in a trust sitting somewhere i
totally agree with you i'm on board let
me tell you two things one i don't mean
this in a negative way i've seen it
happen to me
just wait until you have a wife and kids
and you have like real money and that'll
happen soon enough it might take 10
years or whatever but like it'll happen
but what is what is real money
i mean like
whatever you consider real money to be
you're you're like you have that plus a
zero
so you mean like there comes a point
where you're like
i thought i was rich but now wow yeah
but um
no no
your views are going i don't mean this
like oh you're gonna learn about the
real world no no no dude you might still
be super idealistic and doing all kinds
of cool stuff i hope you are that's
awesome just understand like it's it's
very easy from a certain position to say
well that person in that position should
be doing that they have all kinds of
forces working on them that that are
almost impossible to imagine until you
get there and i'm telling you someone
who started with nothing and went
through all these phases
i just kind of feel like it's uh
at every step of the way
you know i'll tell you this story i
remember watching a video about
climate change activists or something
they went they went to like a oil
executive's house yeah and then they
were protesting in there and then he
comes out right and he sits down with
him and he was like say it all right and
then they started yelling at him and he
just sat and listened and then they were
like what do you have to say for
yourself and he's like i completely
agree with everything you said like
we're we're trying to figure this out
and then he he rebutted with
100 plus million people 200 million
people driving cars every day and
they're telling us we have to do this
and so we're trying to figure out how do
we be better stewards of the earth when
you have 200 million people who are
making demands and if you stop producing
the oil then the government comes and
says why did you stop people are
screaming at us and demanding you do it
so you can't just
the point was
this dude at the highest level was like
supposedly the villain and he's like but
i agree with you the problem is the
machine is controlling you
so my thing is like then you got to just
one day wake up and be like i don't care
for the machine
so you know look my i'm saying
that's easy to say yeah but but 60
million dollars come on somebody hold on
how did you get me defending the machine
i hate them like i am the anti-machine
no here's here's the thing i i
fundamentally fundamentally agree with
your premises the one thing i would
i want to go back to what you said
before uh for a second when you were
like people need to do this and do that
you know why i think so many people are
so what does malice call it black pilled
right now is people he says people are
real no he's white pill so many other
people
uh because i think the old american
story
broke right and whenever it broke and
however it broke it's broken it's
shattered no one believes it anymore and
no one has replaced that story right and
so that most people are followers you
know not good or bad they just are and
right now the dominant narrative in
america is a very toxic destructive
death cult like whatever
crt or wokism or that whole
conglomeration of narratives are
horribly
anti-human and depressing and toxic and
there has been no narrative to replace
it and it's not we're not going back to
old school american exceptionalism
that's not gonna work that story
right or wrong it's broken and no one
believes it anymore so what's the next
story what's gonna replace that i don't
have the answer yeah transhumanism
people becoming cyborgs we've already
got our phone calls look what we're
doing now with zero money we're we're
displaying 100 million people i think
your point is uh uh simply put
i think most people are looking at the
culture right now and thinking
i have nothing in common with these
people right so i won't do anything for
them what's the point and so you know i
describe it as like
our government for instance the titanic
hit the iceberg
they saw it happen everyone else is
clueless they're abandoning ship
but they're still they're stealing the
silverware everything they can do
they got their their vests loaded up
with with silverware and they're in the
lifeboat lowering it down just a routine
test
just gonna go talk we'll be right back
and you're like where are you going with
all that really expensive stuff in that
boat yeah that's what i see happening in
this country i agree but i think that's
a good explanation for why we don't see
more people i think a simple explanation
for you know alex jones is probably that
they're that's top line they're claiming
he has more money than he really does
because because alex i've seen his tank
i've seen the stuff he does when he
drives that armored vehicle around he
does spend a lot of money on this stuff
but i'm just wondering you know
for how many culture warriors there are
um i shouldn't say i'm wondering i i get
exactly what you're saying i think most
people have a large self-interest
and then a smaller
altruistic interest but with no story
they'll mo a lot of people will put
resources behind a great movement
there's no great movement right now i
know a ton of people with like stupid
stupid money private plane private
island money not like me like way more
than me and they're all sitting on it
because even like people who want
you know why they don't know what to do
with it and i don't just mean they don't
know how to invest it or they don't know
how to make money because there's plenty
that just care about making money right
but the ones who want to do the right
thing who would love
to to to back the next thing or help
i
i know they don't know what to do i know
you are correct because i have seen
very wealthy people talk about these
issues and they are clueless as to
what's causing it
and i used to be a fundraiser like i
remember when you would get people who
would come in and say like i just i want
to do something i'm not sure and they
are very susceptible to whoever messages
them i mean that's what a major gift
opera officer for a non-profit or a
school does they court people who need
direction how to donate their money a
really good example i think is look at
all of the twitter alternatives that
exist
like okay you got gab you've got getter
you've got truth social you've got
parlor
this is a really good example of i think
what the issue is is that people are
like hey twitter's banning conservatives
and people who are challenging the
establishment so let's make a new
twitter and the actual reality is the
technology and the platform is not the
problem the problem is culture the
cultural dominance and the issue that
the people who run these companies like
twitter
they are ideologically driven 100 so
when you have a group of people who are
well-off not particularly ideological
driven ideologically except they support
free speech they don't know how to solve
the problem they say let's make a new
twitter congratulations nobody uses it
there's already a place people are
fighting with each other and arguing
what you need is like an elon musk to
buy the twitter that's a clever move but
but what i said to some of these people
when i'm sitting in these meetings i'm
like you guys you really don't get it
it's a cultural problem
you need someone like michael malus
you need you need a masterful troll to
create a cultural shift through a large
cultural shock which is why you know i
mentioned
my view on things is
maybe maybe where i'm getting things
wrong is people absolutely are spending
money but they just don't they're not
addressing the culture problems no
they're not they're spending money on
technology they're spending money on new
companies or new buildings or things
like that or stuff but thinking this is
a positive move to change things
meanwhile the culture keeps churning in
the woke cult direction yes yeah
about two years ago two and a half years
ago i really kind of started to figure
this out and i'll tell you what i'm
doing now uh like
and i don't talk about it a whole lot
publicly just because i'm kind of at the
beginning stages but i've you know i
moved to a re like bought a land moved
to a ranch right but not just like i'm
gonna go be a prepper homesteader like
we're definitely homesteading but i
bought in a place that a bunch of other
people i knew were there and then a
bunch of other people came we started
our own school and now like almost
everything i do now is i i do one of two
things either i think very very locally
like where am i buying my stuff right
like where am i getting water power food
etc like who am i uh um who am i buying
from right
are they in my community um how am i
supporting my community who am i
bringing into my community how are we
connecting uh how are we interfacing
with each other
not to like have some
you know some island or some cult
somewhere i mean we live in texas we're
a town in texas there's a bun but like
i want to think as much as possible
locally i don't i'm i think
that if there's going to be a thread
that is a true counter culture thread
it's going to be around think about how
disconnected and detached everyone is
from each other the opposite of that is
not just interpersonal it's low as much
as possible local i mean obviously i
can't get my oysters locally i live in
you know the desert but like as much as
i can i want to interfa and know my
neighbors and interact with them and buy
from them and sell to them and create
our own economy we have our own school
we literally just started a school we
got 80 families and 100 something kids
yeah that's great like be it just i mean
because
who wants it public schools are disaster
yeah you know like who wants to send
their kids to
yeah i don't even want to get you
blocked on youtube but to to public
schools now right like uh and so i i
that idea has just started on some some
with a lot of people i don't i think
that's going that's gonna be one of the
main ideas but not the only one you know
i i don't know what it's if i knew i'd
be i'd be shouting it from the roof i
want to jump to this next story because
i think it hits at the heart of a lot of
what we're talking about this is uh this
story's been going viral i covered it a
bit in 4 p.m employee wards off three
robbers with a knife stabs one multiple
times at las vegas smoke shop of course
we got to censor these images because
these are brutal images but i'll tell
you just the story
guys working at a smoke shop in vegas
dudes come in one guy immediately robs
him the next guy jumps the counter and
the clerk says okay with a knife in his
hand and just starts going at the dude
who jumped the counter now a lot of
people are saying that it's was it a
legal use of force because he gets this
guy in the neck a couple times and the
guy says i'm dead i'm dead
the reason i i think this is
you know in the previous segment we're
talking about you know why are people
keeping their money hoarding it not
really investing in their communities
and stuff like that and i think there's
a really good example
this guy was attacked
and what people are worried about is
that he will go to prison
for defending himself
and so it's it's things like this when
people say i'm out
if if if we're sitting here looking at
the story thinking that you could be
minding your own business
someone can jump the counter wearing a
ski mask and you are legally required to
back up and wait for them to draw on you
before you have a chance to actually
defend yourself that's the reality of
this country in many states at that
point a lot of people are just like
don't care anymore
i'm gonna i'm gonna watch out for myself
because you will get boot stomped by the
machine if you try and defend your
california totally well the californians
that's why austin's so expensive now
it's because of this like some stuff
like this yeah it's a huge part of it
yeah i mean if you're in florida if
you're well you saw the dude in new york
jose alba right like that guy old guy in
the shotgun yeah like the old dude who
like the the
some so it was in new york the bodega
guy remember the guy who cut the he
killed the the guy was beating him up
like beating his ass
and he stabbed him killed him right
i mean it couldn't have been a more
clear-cut to self-defense the girlfriend
stabbed the store the store clerk the
the yeah she tried to or something no
she did she got emotional dude i'm
pretty sure she got him okay all right i
could be wrong so it was the most
clear-cut self-defense i've ever seen
this jose alba yeah he's leaving and
going to the dominican republic i would
too if i was two hours ago from new york
post yeah yeah yeah they dropped the
murder charge and he said the only
reason the prosecutor dropped the charge
is because everyone in the country was
in a total uproar and the er the mayor
eric adams like all right just let the
dude go
yeah
like it's exactly what you're talking
about kyle right now
exactly the fact that there were people
in this country that were that had had
no idea what happened and wanted him to
to go to prison the fact that he spent
two months or it wasn't two months it
was almost three months
in jail and then they were like oh yeah
i mean it was it was self-defense it's
remarkable that anybody who watched that
work was just unquestionably
let's just watch the video but most
people didn't watch the video because
that one is the wrong narrative but they
believe justice millet
well the same people that believe jesse
smallett are the ones who
when they watch the written house trial
were like wait a minute he didn't shoot
a bunch of black people no like do you
remember no idea do you remember how
many people were like wait a minute he
shot three white guys who had one of
them had a gun
and the other one like and he's on the
ground and the guy runs up with the gun
and the guy they were shocked the guy's
accused of saying that he he regrets not
killing him
they had no idea
and then you saw some of these people
came out they're like i was wrong about
that i
they did a minority did a minute but
most people didn't they kept going with
well huge this is wrong
this is like uh
injustice our system is so biased it's a
it's an example of systemic racism that
you know they never tried to fact check
themselves at all they never really
looked at the case again because they're
not really interested in it they're
interested in their own narrative i'm
sure all of these uh really wealthy
media people
are watching shows like this and they're
they're hearing me talk about stuff
they're laughing like what an idiot the
fact that i would say i would rather
invest in the company than hoard the
money and hide it somewhere they're like
when it all comes crashing down and it
is because they all see it coming taiwan
china russia whatever it is
i'm going to be left holding an empty
bag and they've they've been stocking
their money up in panama and el salvador
and crypto and wherever else their money
might not be worth much
yeah but if you see the school really
things go really sideways you're in a
way better spot than they are well think
about you're on land
you have guns you have friends you have
food yeah but they do too these people
have been buying up in idaho and wyoming
and building
you i'm gonna compounds and
a quick story
so uh you're right that it definitely
exists
but you know what's gonna happen things
go really sideways it's not like a
little covety but like like sideways
sideways civil um
or or short of it can be like short of
civil war but but sideways
um
bro how many people you think that work
on those compounds in idaho are gonna
give their lives for for rich out of
staters yeah it's not gonna okay and
then let's go a step further
how your head is let's say you're a
super billionaire who has a huge estate
outside of sun valley
that head of security
that guy who you know he was former sf
and he's got his family there and he
hired the whole crew and there's like
four dudes that all report to him he's
the billionaire now he's the boss now
that's right that's what happened with
the roman empire i mean the head of the
general praetorian guard would just kill
the emperor and become the new emperor
yep that happened multiple times this is
something people need to understand too
like
your point is absolutely spot on
you own land
so like so so like i i mean rhetorically
obviously but because you talked about
it but i'm saying like you think you own
land in a rhetorical sense what does
that mean you're running it from the
government you've got a piece of paper
that says on this date so and so owns
the land what do you think is going to
happen when it hits the fan you're going
to walk onto your land and there's going
to be a dude with a gun and he's going
to my land and you're going to be like
but i have the paper and he's like and i
have the gun
it's gonna be like the land grab when
people are going west yeah it's gonna
spread that's that's i mean there's a
reason why
a lot of smart people are focusing a lot
of time on community
right and a lot of like that
when i first got into this a lot of
people like oh defense defense have guns
and i'm like okay guns are cool i'm into
defense but i'm one dude if a gang of
dudes come i need neighbors i need
friends well i like other people with
guns this is like an old-timey western
thing but like if you're not home and
your family's home you need the rest of
your community to be like we're gonna
head over there they seem to be in
trouble yeah yes
one dude with a gun is useless against a
gang but a neighborhood gonna win gonna
make it yeah this is what people need to
understand too the left likes to talk
about how 2a
like you you know what did joe biden say
you got it you need nukes to go up
against the government like the afghanis
yeah like the viet cong
they had a hard time
but the thing is it's really simply put
a drone can't occupy a street corner
nope
so if you really want to seize assets
resources and control
a a city a civilization you need boots
on the ground instructing the people
what to do well my favorite about that
is there was someone i can't remember it
was one of like max boot or one of those
lunatics who was like blah blah what are
your stupid ar-15s gonna do against
drones and and uh you know like predator
drones and all stuff and uh i think it
was clay martin who's a total badass he
just responded to max and he said hey
the people operating those drones they
got addresses and families
okay
you know like it's same thing man like
dude people don't realize like do you do
you remember the space force thing i
gotta bring it up again that the
uniforms the space force uniforms were
were like jungle camo or whatever camo
so when they announced space force they
showed a photo of someone wearing a
uniform and it was like what is it
called chris that the green camo they
wear they have different names for it
but uh it's like acu's were the the ones
i wore but is that that reference color
it's just the design yeah yeah so
everybody was laughing they're like it's
the space force but they're like for
them camo yeah so then they started
people started making photos of uniforms
that looked like outer space and there
was like immediately someone said where
do you think the space force is fighting
and they were like
they're on the ground running satellites
secondly if they were in space they
would be in spaceships not floating
around like and even if they were why
would you want them to be invisible
like you're floating in space you want
someone to notice so you can set up an
ambush in space obviously right
my point is all of these people who are
making fun of the idea they are
extremely ignorant they have no idea
what how reality works they it's funny
because we we started doing sales for
emergency food supplies there have been
how many disastrous floods where people
get locked out of resources
there's one just happened in kentucky a
horrible one and when you get your
supply lines shut down and you spend 70
bucks on like a food bucket so you know
you've got freeze-dried food to eat
that's not about the apocalypse no it's
not about but they're all laughing like
uh and now they're like food shortages
coming yeah so my point is just
man
you've got a group of people in this
country people who watch shows like this
who are interested and looking for
nuanced context and then you've got
people who are just like tell me what to
do and how to do it and who to make fun
of yeah oh yeah and they all live in uh
douche cubes in cities and they're all
gonna be in trouble if us if there's any
if all the policies that they love
like let's have green energy cool
where's that coming from
did you see that there was a wind
turbine that was spraying oil
and then everyone went huh yeah there's
a ton of oil how do it's got to spin
it's got like lubricates yeah exactly i
mean at fair point it's not burning the
oil right but they're still they still
require you know how much uh like
un uh un-green energy it takes to
manufacture one of those it's insane man
those things have to run for like 18
years to break even i think and then
don't they have a life span of like 20
or 25 years a lot of them i don't i
don't insane but people don't realize
that
that's like dude please read about
energy okay like fossil fuel energy
we're talking about crude petroleum
we're talking about natural gas it is
ready to be converted yes green energy
is you have to convert all these
materials into a system that can then
convert other energy so it's like a
second layer system
i'm a fan of solar for one reason
not that it's more energy efficient or
more green but that it can give you your
own circuit so all the energy that goes
into the production of the panels you
can then have an isolated circuit you
can be off the grid that's great but you
need sun during a storm you know got it
so now you need batteries
you need a supply chain with solar i'll
put i'll just simply put
it's just it's it's scary when you
realize the majority of people
or i should say at least democrat voters
but you know probably a lot of
conservative voters too they don't know
what they're voting for they don't they
don't they don't understand layer two of
an issue they the left is just like
greta tunberg we gotta ban fossil fuels
now it's like okay 60 million people
dead in three days at least yeah yeah
and i think i think there's estimates of
like a billion people dead in a year if
you cut off fossil fuels no the carrying
capacity of their earth is somewhere
between half a billion to a billion
without fossil fuels yeah that's it like
that's just a yeah so okay
pit put a room full of people a one out
of eight get to live without fossil
fuels that's it that's that's the
reality
i mean like that it's crazy to me it's
not really even debatable you look at
the math on that especially if you want
a quick transition if you're talking
about a 50-year transition okay maybe
maybe it's a little different but you're
talking about a quick transition no i
think about like tapping the vacuum for
energy like the flag vacuum fluctuations
and stuff there's so much technology
fusion for instance um
but
i don't think that the the power
structure wants people to have unlimited
energy they want them attached to a grid
so that they can monitor it and make
sure no one person charged too much
power what does that charge let me let
me pull up this next story here from
blaze this is crazy ceo says two-thirds
of ammunition deliveries have gone
missing with ups that's a lot of ammo so
where is it now
all right maybe this is just one company
patrick collins ceo of thegunfood.com
lost thousands of dollars worth of ammo
because customers orders don't always
seem to make it to their doors
especially when delivering with ups this
is about 18 000 rounds of ammo shipped
through ups only a third were actually
delivered so where is it going okay now
hold on
one company first off eighteen thousand
rounds the ammo
no nothing no so my first thought when i
see this story is particularly
sensational yes
also kind of alarming if it is part of
something
greater
and i think that's kind of what they're
hinting at that things are starting to
break down
so you've got now whether they're gonna
be hiring 87 000 irs agents and they're
giving them hollow points
right they bought hollow points for the
irs and then gates introduced that
legislation that was like no we're not
going to give them ammunition i don't
know what you're talking about yeah so
so it's just
the reason i bring this story up is not
to insinuate that one
company seeing their ammo go missing is
indicative of a collapse but just like
it's another grain of sand in in this
heap with irs agents being armed with
taiwan that uh maybe the fourth turning
is upon us you're familiar with uh
what do you what do you what do you
think and do you think this plays
anything into it i mean
there's a lot of people i'm not sure
what i think about cycles
i'm generational cycles i i mean like i
know enough about physics you know all
energy moves and waves and cycles so
it's almost certainly the uh the it
seems they seem to make a lot of sense
right um
i don't know uh and then fourth turning
is just one of many different historical
cycle type things
i i don't think you have to know
anything about cycles just look around
and be like a lot of
[ __ ] is hitting a lot of fans right now
what do you think happens to a city like
new york
if the supply chain just
was halted all right well here's okay so
not this past winter but two winters ago
i can tell you what happens to a city
like austin when the supply chain is oh
because i was there for the winter
apocalypse you guys remember yes yeah
okay so like i grew up driving in you
know i spent seven years in chicago i
know how to drive in snow and no one in
texas did because it's all texans
californians my my first year in dallas
i remember having to drive everyone
around because i couldn't do it i have
no idea and so it snowed a lot and so
for seven days basically everyone was
locked in but really for four days
everything was truly down
by the end of the by the beginning of
the fourth day one of uh the people who
worked i was still at my company who
worked for my company she was she lived
like eight blocks from the office was
walking into the office right
um because we were all remote so like we
keep working sh she had people trying to
rob her but like these are clearly not
professionals it was like a dude who was
hungry right and i mean
my top my company was
75 people full time in austin at that
point and they were all like millennials
who were like oh well i have cheetos in
my freezer i don't know what that's all
i have like i had to drive i just got
into cow slaughter and so i literally
drove like 200 pounds of meat in to the
office and then a bunch of them walked
in to get it dude [ __ ] went nuts there
there was five and six hour lines to get
like
a bag of pasta yeah like it was bad man
and this is just this wasn't even like
thought the grit didn't go grid kind of
went down a little bit but like it was
bad this is what i'm talking about when
when i tell people like when i do a
pitch for for emergency food i'm talking
about this yes and like sometimes it
rains yes but but you get all these
these leftists that are like mocking the
idea and then when it actually happens
i think this is why i think they're
going to eat each other like it's going
to be and and that's like
bro but i think part of this evening do
you see the new york times already
saying the time for cannibalism or
whatever they're writing about it listen
go ahead have fun you're in new york go
eat your neighbor
i don't care no seriously i don't if
they want to eat your neighbor no if you
want to belong to a death cult then you
get to reap the consequences i don't i
don't belong to that i've prepared i'm
around a bunch of great people who are
all ready to i don't need to worry about
like that's like zombies like you know
but but i mean literally if you have
people who live in new york city they've
got nope they've prepared for nothing
there's clearly signs indicating
something is hitting us right now the
food supply we've been told over and
over again since the start of the year
said
press conference and they're still it's
mocking the idea that they do any kind
of preparation and so i'm just like
it's a zombie horde they don't think for
themselves they don't care to solve
problems they are just standing there in
the crowd mindless and then quite
literally yo
if the supply chain collapses and you
got 2.5 million people on manhattan
island alone let alone central brooklyn
how do you get out of central brooklyn
you don't no stay there but no no but i
mean like
stay there
you're gonna have to try to get out
there's not gonna be food and people are
gonna be it's gonna be it's gonna be
nightmarish yeah no i mean like you like
it's it'll get
it'll get uh abandoned prison camp bad
yep like what like
maybe five days i wouldn't be surprised
if you see slavery
oh way past that yeah i mean roving
gangs warlords like it doesn't take long
to get there in a true grid down
situation what do they say you're three
meals away from a revolution three like
that no 12 missed meals well it's like a
saying it's like i think it's 12 96
hours and 12 missed meals is that what
it is i think
and then people just start uh losing it
yep and then also where to eat your
water from see here out here there's a
river
and uh we also we have a creek as well
and then so we can we can go out and
great and then and then i've got
emergency filters and i've got other
stuff but we also have a well
we got a well
yeah and so if if if everything went
south and the grid shut down or whatever
it's i'd be like just another old day i
guess we got tons of backup batteries
we've got a massive solar backup system
at the new facility we're building but
people in these cities
when when covet happened they're locked
in their apartments they have no food
and they're losing their minds yeah it's
crazy like a stress test
well we just saw it in shanghai
yeah like they went on a hard hard
lockdown and no one knows how many
people died there you know chinese are
real sketchy about that but all those
videos coming out people were like
you see the pictures of people taking
the refrigerator the guy takes the
refrigerator and pushes it onto his
balcony it's open and empty
because they had no food yeah people
were losing it
i remember um when um
it was sandy hurricane sandy oh in new
york
that was bad i was in new york and it
was crazy to see how high the flood
waters got windows were smashed out from
the surge
the coolest thing i saw was when the
downed bus stops skateboarders were
grinding on them so they were having a
blast but then you go to the bodegas
there's no electricity so all the
perishables have expired within a couple
days
and i went in there were two guys
outside holding like two by fours a big
line
and they were like one person at a time
i walked in cash only obviously and the
guy was just like he's like
don't touch the perishables like the
milk everything's bad you don't eat it
but anything that's not perishable like
the the high fructose corn juice and
like the canned stuff is good and so i
went and i was like i got like a coke
and i was like it's warm
you know but it's all you get yo
and the other thing too is people don't
realize how quickly it's going to go to
like
to the 1800s
no more cold drinks no more ice no more
ice cream no more flushing the toilet
nope
you're going back in time real quick
yeah and then the question becomes how
long does it last oh for them that that
so i put it this way new york
gets supply chain disruption like the
whole system just just fails for some
reason
you get a couple days where it's guys
two by fours guarding the bodegas and
people going in three days after that
the food's gone yeah and now it's people
fighting in the streets of the last can
of beans three days after that people
have already started to leave they're
going to be eating fish out of the
hudson and they're going to be barfing
and sick the entire time but i think the
other thing that happens and this we saw
this during covet is those who can like
wealthy people who can afford to move
more quickly will move into upstate new
york connecticut parts of new jersey and
then continue to put pressure on those
systems that don't normally have that
many people there so those grocery
stores will start to feel the effect you
know what you're missing is after the
ritual might go fast but then what
happens you know you hit days five to
ten when all the stores are empty if
nothing's coming in what happens is
people start moving out and not the rich
people the people everyone has to go
walking out yep and not a few of them
but manhattan isn't highlands or
hundreds of thousands so you've got a
few bridges and tunnels right that's it
bottlenecking the whole i know did you
see how they put it's so weird to talk
about this because they just put those
massive metal doors on um
uh the tunnels on the lincoln tunnel yes
no way they call them flood tunnels but
they're not flood tunnels they're
getting ready to lock everybody up
i think so i know it sounds crazy to
even talk about this it sounds lunacy
but they just like i saw was like a
month ago wouldn't it yeah lincoln
tunnel has one and i think the midtown
tunnel
i think all of them maybe
what do i search for flood doors yeah
flood doors lincoln tunnel but what
about how do they stop the bridges you
know i oh yeah look at this i'm not sure
there you go yeah this is a couple years
ago actually
no i so one of them like i know 44
600 pound floodgates installed in nyc
tunnels to protect from super storms
maybe it's because of sandy they were
like it's not unthinkable yeah it's not
it does both yeah stops the water and
the people yeah you can go north out of
manhattan i mean there's still rivers to
the to the west but yeah you can you can
walk north there's no it's just goes up
you can walk but like if things are in
that much chaos how far are you really
going to get on foot oh man
a leak in the lincoln tunnel in 2020
people were freaking out so it could be
why but i do think it's funny that they
put up these big barriers i know dude
bottlenecks is going to be like you know
you see the batman movie where the the
cops block all the bridges and like
nobody leaves the city
i don't know yeah i don't know i don't
you know look
when we were talking about world war one
the other day the crazy thing is people
don't realize how quickly things fall
apart yeah yeah and it was just like
grass was it was it gradually then
suddenly
yeah yeah i think that people
underestimate
how quickly things can fall apart
because they're told to sort of live for
now and live for impulsively i think
this is a lot of like left-leaning
culture that you wouldn't think ahead
like when you say like people make fun
of people who are acquiring food because
they're like oh what do you think it's
gonna be a doomsday it's going to be a
purge all at once like no not
necessarily but also you can't think
past the two days in front of you
because
the impulsivity culture and the
self-indulgence culture tells you that
it's not worth dealing with well that
and then also i mean like in 2019 i made
fun of preppers and i didn't really i
had a couple guns but they were like
hunting like i wasn't
you've converted oh to 100 percent of
course
how could you not after last two and a
half years right but i think it's also
that like
we've grown up in
arguably the richest most abundant
safest period in world history in the
safest country in the world so it's like
who alive has had to deal with anything
truly
catastrophic like we don't i don't know
you know
and so like the idea that this could
happen is just not it's not in the
living memory of anybody right now
yeah we we've had
uh
golden age of sorts at least from our
perspective we've been
the security has been fat and happy fat
and happy i know we've had problems i
know there's been a recession i know
there's been 911 things like that come
on man we've been fat as a culture and
as a country you've been as fat and
happy as it gets exact and and growing
fatter by the day i mean now they're now
you know you know where body positivity
comes from
you you say of course it's because more
too many people so because everyone's
fat so they're all now agreeing with
each other that we're we're just looking
to do this yeah exactly okay go ahead
they've got that works for you they got
that store that what morbid
morbid touring oh yeah toward no i call
it more but on purpose what i was going
to say did they really call it morgan
i call it morbid close enough tim's
gonna buy it call it that and be like
still shop there no i was i was thinking
of of opening a store and calling it
morbid and it would just be like huge
clothes chunkers chompers
but that's a meme so that's okay right
but that's america that's america so i
guess my question my next question is
like how many days until people are
eating each other in new york
like the tunnels are closed and they're
banging on the door and they can't get
out
there's no food
there is i can't remember i read a book
about survival that had like a like a
chart i think it's i think it's under
it's way faster than i thought it's
under two weeks
i can't remember the three days
no
not three days they started each other
that's that's a pretty big taboo to
cross
that would have to be i think that's in
week two but not by the end of week i
don't that's why i don't i feel like
week two i mean
you're you can go a month without food
right
but i guess most people can't when your
muscles start breaking down you're just
and there's gonna be so much panic
people are gonna feel the desperation
sooner than if they were intentionally
you know what you know what would happen
though i bet the first person to get
eaten it's not going to be like some
dude just goes i'm sorry i'm hungry and
like hit somebody it's going to be like
somebody falls down and gets trampled
and then they're like well let's eat
yeah yeah let's eat like you said like
hey it's like lord of the rings meets up
back on the menu boys
dude it's nightmarish to think about the
stuff that's why we got like 50 chickens
no that's why i have two cows and a
flock of sheep 24 sheep and i was i was
reading about bugs and then and what's
the protein called chitin is that what
it's called i don't know
i'm not gonna eat the bugs they're
carapace it's made of that stuff yeah
and i was reading you can't digest it
it's like chitin or whatever yeah
you just you can't digest it and so
that's why you let the chickens eat it
yes and then you eat the chickens or the
eggs you eat the eggs and then when time
comes you eat the chicken yeah and then
it's amazing here's the best part
chickens they make more of themselves
that's crazy they replicate they
replicate and then they just eat the
grass and you've got to make sure
nothing else eats them and then you get
to eat them yep and they taste good
you were talking about like how our
society doesn't have a story right now
yeah i'm a kind of obsessive about
talking about new technology like you
know graphene industry and iron
fertilization of the oceans regrowing
the coral reefs and things like that
yeah sometimes it's really about how you
introduce the ideas because like if
we're in a the moment of all like black
peeling each other like we did it's not
tech i promise you that's not the story
tech might be amazing and it might help
us in a million ways but the the general
feeling from most people is that that
that god has failed then the other idea
is monotheism and god and the
unification of the consciousness but
like i almost feel like i'm selling out
when i do that yeah you know there's
something to be said for that man like
uh i i was ex i've been an atheist my
whole life and then i did psychedelic
medicine like as a therapy and i was
like oh [ __ ] i'm totally wrong of course
god exists it's just not in the way that
religious dogma talks about it's more of
a all things what
that might be but that that story that
might be a little airy fairy for at
least right now i think generally
revivals generally happen after people
have suffered a lot we're going into the
suffering phase not fourth turning phase
yeah
2028 should be fun though
six more years i'll be in my 40s i don't
know i think we got at least a decade
there's a lot of unraveling to happen i
kind of like what's what's the worst
case scenario for somebody who lives up
for someone who lives in the middle of
nowhere i mean asteroids strike no no i
mean like society collapsing
hold on hold on
like this is really important living out
in the middle of nowhere by yourself
you're actually not you're better off
than in a city not a great spot
like being in a in the country with a
community that's the better spot like
where you you're not
way off by yourself you're actually an
easy target you know and you don't have
anyone around to help you know whereas
if it's like us and like eight neighbors
or you kind of know your neighbors
that's a different situation the
fortress around you doesn't necessarily
have to have a fortress like it doesn't
have to be a castle right you just have
to kind of know dude i i joke about like
one day we'll be we'll be hanging out
we'll be doing the show and we'll hear
like a noise and then we'll like run
outside and there'll be some hipster guy
and like flannel with a beanie on a
handlebar mustache trying to steal a
chicken and he's like i'm just hungry
and we're like stop him
chase him down he like absolutely led
brooklyn dude in texas all you you paint
your fence posts purple and you put no
trespassing sign because that's
basically the you know if you come on
land we're gonna shoot you purple yeah
purple that's like the color that is
purple heart why is that i don't know it
did that just picked that
color color and like deoxygenated blood
no dude one like one of the weird things
about texas like animal wrestling you
could you just shoot like if if you like
your animals in a field then you've you
know posted and whatever and someone's
in there
like no you're that's where you can
shoot them in the back it doesn't matter
you're not going to prison yeah like you
don't steal animals in texas you get
shot it's bad
yeah i'm sure those laws go way back
do you think that i that we because i
think we are building the story for the
future right now maybe nothing we say
today is gonna cause it to change
tomorrow but in 20 years when people are
like i've had enough right they'll look
at this video right and that will be
what inspires them right what do you
think like psychedelics god no i mean
psychedelics are just a tool i'm not
like i like psychedelics i use them as
medicine like they've been
transformative for me but i'm not like
you know uh bless his heart like i love
aubrey marcus but i'm like oh you got
everyone's gotta do ayahuasca no
everyone doesn't you know like they're
just a tool to achieve a goal they're
not the thing like imagine if i was
super into hammers like what why but if
i'm like i want to build a lot of houses
for people to live in you're like oh
okay that makes sense so i just look at
psychedelics as the hammer right i kind
of i've always kind of felt that there's
a lot of people who really need some
kind of
hammer experience hammer that's one way
to put it because i don't wanna numbers
aren't important
but but i don't want to
i don't mean just like one thing like
dmt or something like that but i think a
lot of people are like locked in their
minds they can't they can't see outside
the box it really shocked me awake with
the first time i took mushrooms i was
walking around manhattan beach and uh
looking at it it was trash night and i
was like where does this trash go what
have we done as a species you needed
mushrooms we're just yeah we're just
like no but that's the point but it hit
my core it changed my core like the it
changed my dna and the way i was
perceiving it this is exactly what i
mean yeah though right from for me i
remember you know i would talk to my
friends and they would start asking
these crazy philosophical questions or
like when they were stoned or something
and i was like i don't need whatever it
is you're doing to ask these questions
but clearly you do
maybe there are some people who are like
mindless cogs but then they they have an
experience like ian was saying and also
they start asking themselves where's
that garbage going then they realize hey
wait a minute probably not somewhere
good just like so many problems they're
just putting in on an island and waiting
for it to go away they put on a garbage
barge kick it out and forget about it of
course there's now we find there's
mushrooms and bacteria that'll digest it
and turn into sugar there's lots of
cleansing i think some of it is the
substance is it takes away the
inhibition people may think about this
thing on some level but they don't want
to ask because they don't want to be the
only one they want to blend in and not
but but ian asked himself
right but you were saying your friends
are posing these questions to you while
you're hanging out there's like a
there's like a desensitization without
the psychedelics like real like right
now you're kind of blending into the
wall i see like the scene but when i'm
on psilocybin you stand out life is very
different than non-life it becomes very
apparent that we have created this thing
or someone before me built this freaking
set that we're on and now
you wake up one day and you're here and
you're like stuff that exists it creates
a value for for life i think um at least
psilocybin
i think a big problem one of the big
problems we've had is that millennials
and to an extent every generation before
it but
growing in scale
don't understand that other people did
work to make things exist that you have
so like for example i remember i was
riding my bike across the williamsburg
bridge
in new york and i just thought to myself
like man
some people worked really really hard to
make this bridge happen and i don't
think twice when i ride my bike over it
i don't pay for it i have no i mean i
got city taxes cover that costs but it's
just there well one day there was some
dude or some lady and they were just
like yo we need a bridge and then all
these humans were like
let's work really really hard and and
sweat and tears and probably a lot of
people died in construction and now all
these people are just like what do you
mean the bridge is just there and it's
like you don't you don't understand the
value of what was gifted to you just and
and the thing about the bridge is you
could be a tourist and you get free use
of it
like you're not paying anything for this
it's just there and you get it i think
that is like the generational wealth of
millennials and and now gen z they don't
understand how much blood sweat and
tears went into making the world so
comfortable
so
i don't think any young people do i
didn't understand when i was 25. i'm not
sure if it's that generation
specifically i'm more gen x i guess
and like i was a [ __ ] idiot 25 yeah
what the hell is it
yeah right and i know my parents were
because they're still idiots yeah in
their 70s right so like yeah
i mean i think in ayahuasca no yeah i'd
love it
we need people to get access to their
ancestral knowledge what i'm talking
about
you mentioned earlier you don't think
the technology is the
story but like
in the past the story was told through
new technology like the printing press
allowed us to proliferate the story of
or writing allowed us to proliferate the
idea of god to the masses so maybe that
the metaverse or that the internet is
the is the vessel that the story will be
told so the post-world war ii story in
america was that progress
solves all and progress is the goal
where has that gotten us
modern monetary right theory what is
progress
it was uh the the story coming out of
world war ii was that progress the
american story is a story of progress
right
i i that it's just prog but like
it's like the the the concept of growth
for the sake of growth is the philosophy
of cancer right progress just to make
progress because it's technical
technological progress is serving a
different god it is not serving humans
right whereas like i would contrast that
to
like an idea that could and i mean a
meta idea that could replace that would
be prosperity what does prosperity for
humans look like because it does not
always in fact rarely does it mean more
technology in fact more technology is
usually antithetical to prosperity for
humans it might be great for
owners god i sound like a goddamn
marxist right now but it's
and i'm not at all i really am not i
can't stand them interesting philosophy
but but if they honestly if there was
one thing karl marx got right it was at
least the beginning of a critique of
understanding that that that there is a
relationship between a human and the
value they create that matters that's
not captured
in the normal way you calculate capital
right and so like what is wrong with
your show you're getting to defend the
system it marks up going crazy i know
yeah this is not called no but but
process like i'm a big believer now like
in
the way to measure
anything is how does this benefit humans
humans not stakeholder capitalism and
that's all nonsense that's all a scam to
screw people but like how am i better
how is my neighbors better how's my
family better how my kids are better how
am i animals better right
and like i like technology when it
serves humans and prosperity but like
a lot of it doesn't man can i ask a
question sorry to interrupt how does
this prosperity doctrine fit in with
like your past because i feel like in
some ways you had a very different
mindset in your 20s when you were like
the pickup artist and you were like
don't you ever you can call me anything
but not pick up artists you want to call
me a scientist
i actually would not be upset if you
called me a marxist based on what i just
said because i kind of sound like one
but not pick up artists that's sorry
what's the technical term for the
industry that you were sort of the head
of i was a writer uh-huh yes that's what
we're gonna call it
are you teaching people how to hook up
no
no i never did that sorry he was writing
no he no no no no don't put me look i
like neil strauss i know i'm another
crew i was never one of them i was never
in that world i wrote
i if you want to put me in a category
but i mean i the new york times said i
invented my own literary genre which
like it's in new york time so whatever
but like you don't put me in a category
put like bukowski or hunter s thompson
or that sort of stuff
no like writing about
women is not like that has a long
history yeah i get that but what i'm
saying is your
books and i'm not critiquing you at all
like it's just part of your story no no
you can critique me just don't call me a
picklebar i don't that's a different
thing what is the word what is you were
a writer who specialized in a very
writing about my life writing your life
which had a lot to do with i was like a
20 something year old dude who got drunk
and hooked up and act like an idiot like
ultimately and now you're someone who's
saying and i think it's cool but like
we need to think about
how we are affecting the humans around
us how we're affecting change how we're
affecting humanity where did you come
like how did this transition happen for
you
that's a very different question than
how did you go from a pickup artist
who's going to write a book now called i
know they serve beer
honestly it's a great question though it
really is um uh
look i i i could say simple as well i
grew up in mature but it's more than
that it's
honestly like i had to do my emotional
work like i had to face mice all the
stuff i didn't want to face all my
trauma all my issues all the baggage
that we all carry around i carry around
just as much as anyone
and i can just carry it around if i want
and that's what most people do but at
some point i realized and it was
actually after a lot of success i had
way more success than i thought i needed
to be happy and i was like 10 happier
right it's way better to be rich than to
be poor like it's much nicer but it's
like only that much better and i was
like well okay this and so i fixed
everything in my life externally and i
was still unhappy and like the only
thing left is me like that's it like
that and that was not an easy pill to
swallow and that was into my you know
mid-30s started therapy and therapy was
a talk therapy it was like a serious
in-depth psychoanalysis and it was it
was fine like it was good it helped me a
lot
but it didn't really connect to me to
myself and my emotions and there's a lot
of ways to do that for me the thing that
cracked me open was mdma therapy like uh
that um
was just
mind-blowing to me and that was when i
was like oh my god i can feel love and
sadness this is like i
and then that's like i started about 40
years ago and that's really what
i kind of knew all this intellectually
and i believed it but i didn't get it
really until i started to connect with
myself and once you connect with
yourself then you connect with nature
and that's when i was like oh like
of course god exists and i'm like i
literally i'll never forget i did a
session with mdma nlsd and i like i had
the experience of of like
it sounds crazy you've never done
psychedelics but like the experience
that not i didn't talk to god but the
experience of god and i remember i
called my friend who's mormon and i'm
like dude i thought you were just an
idiot who was fooled and he's like no
i'm like i i get it now god is an
experience you're not actually he's like
yes
and i'm like ah [ __ ] dude i'm so sorry i
just thought you were stupid
really and i'm like
which a lot of religious people can be
like there's oh i'm gonna believe this
because my mom said so but he's like one
of those who really like has a
relationship what he calls a
relationship with god and i understand
what it means now right um i don't frame
it the way he does but i get it and so
once you start walking down that path
then i think um
there's two ways there's multiple ways
to go down that path i because like a
lot of what i'm saying you can get kooky
esg clowns who are like we need to you
know kill a bunch of humans to save the
planet no i am not on that path
but uh once you start connecting to
yourself and you connect everything
around you i think it
it just
i don't think anything i'm saying is all
that revolutionary she's like oh of
course
you know this just feels right this
seems right this connects with
what i have experienced right um i don't
know is this am i rambling or is this
major short answer is mdma that dude i'm
telling you
it has been the most important thing
i've ever done it's incredible number
one
incredible substance i've never used it
in um in a therapy session but they do
that for soldiers that have returned
that are suffering ptsd and things like
that yep yeah no right now it's in stage
three clinical trials to be legalized in
2023. so it's not legal like i had to
find underground guides and all that but
um uh when you do it a lot i mean you
can do it on your own i don't i like to
have a guide and whatever but um they
don't really do much they're just kind
of there but dude it's been it is
i've probably done 15 sessions in the
last four years and it is the most
important thing i've ever done in my
life and i'm married
and i have four kids and people like not
your kids and your wife i'm like i
wouldn't be married and i'd be a
terrible father like if i had not found
it seriously like truly it's amazing
when you cry being able to cry dude the
first time i ever felt love really was i
thought i had felt love i was married
with two kids when i first did mdma
therapy
and i like almost as soon as it really
hit i'm like oh my god
i had never felt like i never nothing
remotely that deep ever in my life until
i did that i didn't realize how
traumatized and how emotionally
constipated i was you know and i had no
idea i had no idea and then as i got
deeper man man i got into the grief god
that was about two three two and a half
years in it was nothing but grief man
for like a year it didn't matter what i
did i had so much grief in me
um like that i had to feel that i pushed
away my whole life i just wouldn't feel
how did you stay sane between sessions
while you were trap processing
it's a great question i had uh so really
really good uh mentors around who had
walked this path decades before and kind
of knew and helped me but it's basically
called integration right so you know i
had a talk therapist a different one
from before um you know and i i actually
had to really learn self-care truly deep
like okay i can't be working 15 hours a
day anymore i can't this i can't that's
not gonna work and so
journaling every day which i've been
doing for a while anyway but i got
serious about it um you know like got
very serious about nutrition very
serious about sleep
um all this sort of stuff and i i mean i
changed it's crazy for me to think about
what i was like even six or seven years
ago but especially like 10 or 15 years
ago
um
it was
in a lot of ways i was the same person
but not it's it's almost like i don't
even know that dude from 15 years ago
like he's like i like i almost just feel
sad for him you know do you ever want to
change your name no no no no not at all
no no i don't mean this in a way like
repudiate my past or i was a bad person
no i mean i did some terrible stuff i
should have done but like i don't mean
it like that i just mean like
i don't have any connection to that dude
so your diet you're talking earlier that
you
source most of your meat from your farm
and a lot of stuff locally like what did
it used to be what did
i mean you know like i i've been eating
healthy for about 15 years meaning like
kind of like a paleo ancestral diet you
know not a lot of carbs no seed oils i i
knew that but like i just it was like oh
yeah you know i mean i go to whole foods
that chicken's got to be healthy man
have you seen how chickens are raised
and he doesn't well i'm sure you they're
horrible right they don't even walk they
get stuffed and oh dude it's the worst
and so like once you kind of understand
that it's like okay
you eat what the animals eat
right so if they're even if they're
healthy chickens organic and they're
raised in these horrible you know
massive pens where they you know all
they don't walk on the ground they walk
on dead chickens or whatever it's like
that's terrible that's unhealthy we got
farms all over the place out here yeah
you drive five minutes you get
fresh farm tenderloins you get fresh
eggs fresh butter yep man we've been
cooking with real farm butter it's like
amazing it is it's it's inc
you can't compare it not like so we've
got salted and unsalted and you taste it
and you're like
what is this
and then you take the store-bought
butter and you're like this is not food
no it's not it really is it's actually
not in a lot of cases yeah it was
interesting you were talking about like
the story of our time and it sounds like
it's kind of a personal thing for the
individual needs to realize their own
story
uh like what you did with and the mdma
therapy and talk therapy basically was
the talking the mdma is the tool that
you use during the talking right well
one's about the intellect and ones about
the emotions you gotta go both like you
can't just do i know plenty of people
who've done a ton of emotional work but
are flighty as hell and have dumb ideas
in their head right and then i know to
plenty of people who've thought their
way as far as they can but won't feel
anything right it they're both are
important both are relevant uh and you
can't just do one you know like if you
want to be balanced and and kind of
whole you kind of have to you have to
feel and think there's that's why we got
different parts of our brain it's not
just one or the other when you like come
up on a situation that makes you want to
cry or it makes you want to like what at
what point do you stop yourself from
crying and at what point do you let
yourself cry i try not to stop myself
from look i mean unless like it's
inappropriate or weird or i'm at like
some i don't know you don't want to cry
right dinner and the butterfly if you
guys gave me a reason to cry i would cry
like that there's i mean i'm not sure
like what it would be like i'm sure we
could talk about something but um yeah
like i don't i
i don't really worry about that anymore
like that's never i've never been
worried about well what does someone
else think about like
my emotion that's never been a problem
for me uh it's for me it's been feeling
the emotion you know like uh
i i didn't have that bad of a childhood
in certain ways like no one sexually
abused me or beat me or thank god none
of that i just had narcissistic parents
who didn't care about me and i was
essentially abandoned as a kid you know
not literally like i had food and
shelter but like emotionally there was
no one there for me
and that sort of relations called
relational trauma that sort of a
relational trauma is actually it's hard
to understand because there's not a
great narrative around it and most
people don't understand the closest
person i've ever heard who understood
was someone who actually helped they
were in the uh
romania after the fall of the wall and
there were all these abandoned kids and
they worked in orphanage there and they
would tell me like the romanian
orphanages are
crazy right so my life wasn't that bad
but imagine like
like like someone like that who had
parents and were there but still kind of
ignored you so it's like on the scale of
relational trauma they're like a 10 and
i'm like a five right but it's still
anywhere on that scale it's not good and
so like um uh like
just accepting that right that okay i
wasn't sexually abused or physically
abused i've never been to war you know
no one's raped me like most people think
of trauma as some horrible physical
event and that is trauma but um that's
not the only type of trauma and that's
not the only way to have deep emotional
impacts from things you know and it's
not like dude some people will do this
and like all kinds of uh repressed
trauma will come up like oh my dad or my
stepdad raped me and i pushed that
happens all the time none of that
happened with me like i i knew exactly
what happened to me it was just like
i had never felt any of my grief for my
mom
never spending any time with me like i
just pushed that away because when
you're four it's overwhelming
you know but now when you're 40 and
you're taking mdma and you're laying on
this sofa and you know new york wherever
and like it comes up and it's like oh
and you like safe and whatever you can
feel it then you feel it you know but
then it's like it's like you're free now
does this
impact how you parent i'm assuming or do
you make different choices i mean i
i thought if you want me to start crying
if i think about what i was like as a
parent seven years ago with my first my
bishop my oldest who just turned eight
versus now like i was
on the scale of parents i was a very
good parent compared to most parents
seven years ago i am a fundamentally
different parent now i'm a hundred times
better i'm so much more present more
emotionally connected more
attached i meet my children's needs so
much better
um you got him learning like brazilian
jiu jitsu
he does go to residual actually like my
eight-year-old does it oh yeah yeah yeah
totally 100 yeah yeah um but okay funny
you bring that up well when he was four
i pushed him into it you know because
like i'm big into that i really and he
liked it but like he kind of didn't
really want it and i was pushing a
little too hard and i was i just was
wise enough to realize all right i'm
pushing him i'm not gonna do that i'm
not gonna you know yeah and so then i
backed off and he quit
okay like i was disappointed which is
like silly because it's his life not
mine
and i stopped uh i let go of all that
and then two years three years later
he's like dad i want to start going
again you know what kids need for this
stuff i they need to be have other kids
around them yeah so the issue is when
you you bring your kids say like
brazilian jiu jitsu and it's a bunch of
adults yeah and he went to kids classes
so all right well i typically what i
find i think it was i was just pushing
him like he was pushing him too hard
yeah he was he didn't want me looming
over him right you know and want to hang
out with their friends that's kind of
the point i was getting too right so
like i've had friends who uh one example
of skateboarding a friend of mine
uh
said they wanted to skate got a
skateboard and then eventually didn't
want to do it anymore but their parents
were like you have to
we bought you a board you're using it
yeah but then when you have all of these
other skateboarders all cheering you on
and then you have your own group of
friends all of a sudden you're like this
is my community you get into it yeah and
so you know yeah well but there's also i
think an in intrinsic versus extrinsic
right and so
my son's pretty independent and
thankfully and i was pushing him and i
think he was naturally rebelling against
that and so when i stopped pushing and
let go then he was able to find it on
his own and his own desire for it as
opposed to mine so pushing a little is
probably a good thing just so he knows
introducing is a good thing pushing is
different
and you also should have him play magic
the gathering 100 percent well it'll
make him a good poker player exactly
mathematician so so a lot of people
don't understand um
magic gathering is chess and poker
combined and a lot of the top magic
players were actually top poker players
there's a famous quote from from one of
these guys and they said you know you
play magic the gathering and poker
is you know what is like is it being a
top poker player harder and he's like if
one game has 13 000 cards you're trying
to guess one has 52. he's like so you
know poker is a bit easier for us but it
was it was a good point and i was i
remember when i was younger trying to
explain it to people
people often hear magic the gathering
and they assume you like dress like a
wizard yeah and then you're like duns
and dragons yeah it's it's like you go
to uh you go to a local game shop
and there's like you know i i would i
would be skateboarding and then
afterwards i'd go to the game shop
there'd be comics there'd be art we
would play marvel vs capcom and then
people would play you know magic or
whatever and none of these people
weren't a dnd not a single one played d
and d it was just like really there's no
overlap between those two
there probably is i i i assume there are
oh yeah right but in my comic shop there
was none there was no dnd oh wow it was
comic books it was marvel it was it was
you know
playing arcades it was skateboarding
yeah it was just like another thing we
were tired where bodies were racked we
was like i just don't have a backside
tail slide it's like let's just draft or
something so we can sit down and still
do something and so then you're getting
strategic strategic development yeah
after your physical development
yeah no it makes sense yeah now the same
company owns uh dungeons and dragons and
magic the same company owns them both so
you might start to see overlap but
that's like completely different ones
like like do you play d d it's like an
acting exercise basically and the other
game is like a math exercise we really
got to do that modern political war game
thing that that clint the clintons or
was it was it clinton it was like
podesta did
do you hear about that in 2020 they
basically played d and d but it was like
modern politics
and then like one of the democrats was
like if trump wins we're succeeding from
the union and like they rolled roll die
to see what would happen yeah
that would be funny we really got to do
that we could film it it'd be hilarious
that would be funny you get a bunch of
people in who were super into that that
would be fun look at ian you're hillary
you're running in 2024. all right let's
go
what do you say roll to see if you're if
you've got the votes yeah roll to see if
people actually like you this time
good luck no no no you don't well you
you do your base stats but like i'm
pretty sure her charisma would be like
yeah i'd be like a minus one minus one
oh hillary it goes down it wasn't always
that bad what would trump have in terms
of like you know charisma
15 or 16 really high very high yeah very
high but isn't
his intelligence would be lower
he's got more charisma and intelligence
intelligence would be high too what's
like a negative wisdom he'd have low
wisdom yeah a negative because he pisses
people off with his statements yeah yeah
and then we got to do this yeah like why
did he say that he's like i don't even
know why i said that
because of my low wisdom you're right he
isn't he is very intelligent oh yeah
yeah he's a calculating guy yeah yeah
this would be hilarious map out we
should we should we should literally do
we should do it live
and um
like war game out what 2024 would look
like based on modern politics today to
see what it would be you know dude
desantis have like there's all kinds of
wild cards too we would do like a
primary and then it's like you gotta
roll to see if you get the votes or
something i'm liking ron desantis more
and more hey you guys see carrie lake
won uh finally finally after so much
time she won every county she was great
i was in favor of her when she called
out that cnn woman i'm like
she's obviously amazing she's accessible
at least to me so far i've interviewed
her i've been on the show we interviewed
her twice and like we talked about a
local voting app that you could use
where like you could set your slider for
like i want to put seven percent of my
taxes towards this local thing four
percent towards this and it'd be like a
tinder app kind of where you could i
could say like okay hey everyone i want
to put a fountain on main street and
then if people are going through the app
they see it they swipe right it goes
into their little slide bar thing and
then they can allocate like two percent
of their taxes to the thing and she
loved the idea that's i think it's it's
really like things are becoming very
real with with the governors
that's an example of technology that
could be amazing
that's very cool yeah you went to the
convention of states i keep hearing it
get tossed around i mean
i don't know like uh i don't a wooden
shot there's almost nothing you could
tell me about the future of america that
would shock me now like a complete
chaotic civil war
a federalist you know kind of quasi
breakup but not really i don't know
something woke communist gulags
of course that wouldn't
like they already have those in
australia yeah yeah
yesterday that it seems like all the
cultures on earth now have come together
and they're all forcing each other on
themselves and so that's this chaos it's
not like an accident or like oops we
[ __ ] up it's like no this is like this
is what happens
he got ian swearing yeah i'm back to my
old self
nothing would make me happier than just
like local rule for everyone you know
like okay you take care of yourself
we'll take care of ourselves let's just
like
i i got no problem you wanna
inject hormones into your your kids and
eat each other okay cool go to new york
that's why they do that except they want
rules over you of course right no i
guess that's the thing and we gotta meet
up with the 100 fear and like the rivers
and the oceans well that's the control
thing that's like okay if i can find a
lever of control where you where you are
responsible for something i want that's
i'm convinced
without before
i've been skeptical of climate stuff for
a long time for two reasons one is
because the people who are pushing it
are always the same people who are
pushing whatever authoritarian
[ __ ] that comes up right so it's
never like so someone i'm like okay well
this person's really smart and they know
their stuff it's always like you know al
gore right who's like it's that type but
then the other thing is it's like hold
on a minute so
you
want to make me responsible for
something that you get you can't really
measure
you can't attribute to me
but it's going to have to fundamentally
alter my behavior and my output but you
get to decide what that is
no that's not going to work right and
like whenever someone's like you know
trying to make other people responsible
for something and it means they get to
control them that's the reddest of red
flags even if like yeah i mean you can
look at the data it's gotten hotter in
most parts of the world last couple
years or whatever etcetera etcetera like
even if there's some truth to it the
more tangible example would be like
poisoning the waterway inadvertently
upriver like dumping chemicals in and
then the other community that you're not
that's measurable like you could okay
you dumped ddt up here all these fish
died like okay like you can figure that
out you know
like that's like that that's tort law
can handle that
you know
you are a lawyer after all before you
said no no no no i did not take the ball
for it let's go to we're gonna go to
super chats okay if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show with your friends
and uh head over to timcast.com become a
member to check out our new shows tales
from the inverted world the new episodes
sunday sundays at 10 a.m the next
episode is really amazing it's what got
me thinking about uh the great filter
and the apocalypse and stuff but uh this
is shane cashman exploring the mystery
of the lost confederate gold there's a
bunch of weird stuff in there death
threats someone threatened to kill him
but also the uncensored tim cats show
which are uh monday through thursday 11
pm so we got a full uh we got four of
those up for you right now from this
week but let's read these super chats
all right let's jump over and see if i
can read this it's a lot harder to read
because youtube crashed out on us again
so i'm gonna i'm gonna try and read i
have to like lean forward
all right let's see
oh actually we can't read them that's
amazing okay we can read some kade
shriner
first super chat ever i just wanted to
say one thing love y'all guy ian is the
best though well hey we're all equal
now you know i'm just doing what i do
hey dude like i am the best thank you
for noticing i'm the best at what i do
it's a very diplomatic answer all right
scott wood says thank you for the heads
up on food shortages gas shortages
i got 70 gallons of gas on hand never
paid over four dollars a gallon freezer
full of food what do you what do you
what do you do when you stock up on gas
well gas doesn't appreciates quickly
he's got to cycle that stuff through
diesel lasts about a year gas won't
usually last more than three months or
so because of evaporation no no because
it the way it's uh processed like
propane will last essentially kerosene
lasts forever effectively diesel i think
is about a year to 18 months and i think
gas has to turn over quickly oh so you
can cycle it without destroying it no no
you got to use it
like it won't last i think there might
be additives you can put in but i don't
think they extend it beyond six months
raymond g stanley jr says tim seeing
death in real life is exactly why
veterans are some of the biggest
adversaries of war once you see life
drain from someone's eyes you get it yep
yeah when i saw that video today of the
guy in the store
it just brought like
memories back and feelings man and i
always i always say like
i'm not like a war i'm not like a
soldier or anything i didn't do any of
that stuff but i've been places where
people have died and i've i remember the
first time i saw someone die and the
feeling i got was something that i had
never experienced in 27 years of life
seeing it actually happen was just it
was like
i don't know felt like
getting having like just water
submerged my brain like it was a flicker
and then there's like this gut-wrenching
feeling like someone was squeezing my
heart and i watched them carry that body
off the street this crazy man yeah and
watching this stuff earlier today and
i'm just
man i'm the crime that's skyrocketing
these these woke soros backed da's
there soros writes an op-ed saying he's
doubling down on all of this we're
watching people get slashed in the
street there was a guy just in new york
i think it was today he was going around
uh or the other day was just punching
people in the face
it's just it's absolutely bonkers
violent crime is up all over the country
and it's been on the rise since covid
probably before that
and then you start seeing these stories
like
the shop owner who fires a shotgun to do
with the rifle and it's like man
this is not going in a good way and
people are going to get a rude awakening
when they like there's so many people
that think they want to live in like a
zombie apocalypse horror movie and they
think it'd be fun and exciting no and
then they're sitting there shaking with
more stress they've ever experienced in
their lives and they're throwing up just
because of the anxiety
it's crazy days
man all right
we'll grab some more super chats alex
maggiore is that
maggie i see the 4pm story becoming the
new norm people are tired of the
lawlessness and it's going to result in
vigilantism frontier justice and maybe
mafia-like protection rackets yes yes
do you see what what brazil did they um
they have a huge problem with guys on
motorcycles robbing cars and they
legalized like you can run over those
more and like there's all kinds of
videos now coming out
yeah
just mowing people down with their cars
yeah oh yeah
like people getting robbed and then a
car just comes out of nowhere
runs right over the bike yeah kills
people all those yeah i mean they're
killing robbers but right the thing is
there's there's a there's a point where
it's someone robbing you for luxury that
they just they want right then there's
also like you mentioned with the the
with the with austin with the the winter
apocalypse
people just have no they're desperate
yeah and they're like that's different
you or me but then you're going to see
people like when it's about luxuries
an armed population on our society it's
a polite society if there's some guy
who's going to rob a store because he
wants to come up on something and he
knows everyone's armed he's going to
think twice
somebody who's starving they don't care
no you're right it's like i was telling
the story when i saw a fox walking into
our backyard yeah it's like a yard it's
like a big open acreage of the forest
but uh bucko bokus our cat was sitting
there like a [ __ ] just in a loaf and
looks over at the fox that's slowly
creeping up to him the fox was gaunt
looking
i was surprised the fox came onto the
property because we have you know that
we have dogs
and
humans
but this fox looked
desperate didn't care so i actually had
to stop in the middle of recording run
out and start yelling and the fox just
looked at me and didn't care like he was
that hungry it looked it looked gone it
was probably just so i had to just jump
off and then run up and then it ran off
yeah and then i had to yell at my cat
like what are you doing you [ __ ] he's
gonna eat he's still sitting this whole
time the cat is just like what yeah and
he just looks at me and just looks back
and then doesn't move he's too
comfortable i was like but then i i i
went over and i get back inside you
[ __ ] we let them run around and do cat
stuff because for the most part they're
fine i know you can you're on the risk
of like coyotes and stuff like that but
we had a raccoon coming on the property
because they were getting desperate they
were getting hungry or something
and then when they're desperate they
don't care about the threats so it's
time to like not wear jewelry out in
public not hold your phone up in front
of you on the street in new york if
you're walking down the street or just
not be in new york yeah
all right tim wolex has been managing
money for four years
for ultra wealthy trusts are not the
best way to shelter money irrevocable
trusts give the money to someone else
you can't be the giver and receiver of
cash what is it what does that mean well
no he's right for that's one type of
trust is irrevocable right so meaning
like uh if i set up a trust for my son
that's irrevocable so it's gone to him
fully it just makes it more protected so
i can't be like there's because
sometimes you can pierce the veil with
trusts and like you know like in a
lawsuit depending on which trust it is
irrevocable you can't can't do that
here's someone else's money yeah it's
now someone else's money totally right
so you gotta pay taxes on it like well
you always have there's nothing you're
doing you're not paying attention but i
mean like let's let's say you you make
uh a hundred grand i pay taxes
i
i don't think the other person has to
pay taxes once they take the money out
they might have to right uh no
i'm not sure i don't think so
it depends well so it depends it depends
how it's set up because i know like uh
for kids
i think they're each allowed to get
there's a number uh five or ten million
uh from their parents maybe five million
a piece from parents that's tax
free and then after that it's like death
tax where it's like 80 or whatever crazy
amount and so like i think that that if
it's
somebody else then i'm not sure how that
would work yeah
all right
jordan c says signed up for tim cast a
few days ago also tim in response to the
line from fast and furious it was from
fast five when they were in brazil not
four ah
fast five
you're slipping fact checks are live
here the uh the fast the furious
cinematic universe is the best cinematic
universe yeah
this is the one where there's like ten
of them well the best for what
i'm just saying like race cars i mean
how many cinematic universes are there
two
marvelous star wars star wars lord of
the rings
no i'm completely opposed we talk about
this on pop culture all the time it's
the best it's no it's too many just stop
it it's just like explosion pretend fake
why dialogue they go to space because
they had to go to space what do you mean
it was amazing you could be fascinated
ludacris was in outer space
in a fiero
gender thing like i maybe just don't get
this but like
this seems stupid to me that's why it's
awesome stupid it was about race cars
and like races for the first couple yeah
and then it became about an action
adventure movie where they then they
were like we gotta do something we
better keep writing the script no it's
on purpose like they did the movie hobbs
and shaw which is my song and there's
like idris elba's got superpowers and
i'm like yes then the next movie they go
to outer space and i'm like even better
i hope i swear please if you're
listening to me please studio the next
movie maybe the next one is you're
already working on it the one after that
i want there to be like a quantum
explosion that gives them all super
powers yeah they've got the diesel
starts floating they're gonna no longer
no no they should be woke
epidemiologists that's what i'm talking
about they shrink one guy down goes into
the body the other guy and that's the
fight dudes and organs
like that blue
cartoon character that did that that
movie's already been made no i opposed
this vehemently i i ten is too many tim
i want them to get super powers
and then like you know ludacris's
character and then they fight the marvel
characters
they got to make their own villains you
know and then but then it's just like
all of a sudden you've got this
cinematic universe
jason state jason statham can teleport
for some reason
and you know the rock can like you get
super strength because he's the rock
vin diesel can fly that's organic
superheroes that's how they're made you
know you have to talk about this when i
told brad i was like opposed to this he
was like you don't understand they make
so much money like they can keep going
forever but why why would we do this
well because people pay and we do talk
about creating culture and making new
things as opposed to rehashing the same
crappy marvel characters so maybe that's
what this universe has become or is
because it needs to it's new crappy
instead of old crap no no no i agree it
sucks but maybe change the name from
fast and furious because that's i still
think of cars and what the first guy i
mean they call it hobbs and show was
fast and furious presents presents
no superpowers it would be they went to
outer space they should they should
eventually like they're in the
multiverse then you put spider-man in
there for some reason like you were
saying is it a disney stargate
star game just watching a clip from that
earlier james spader we should do it we
should totally do a bit somehow where
it's like fast and furious 57 and it's
like spider-man's in it they go through
a stargate into the multiverse
57 chevy to fight klingons
this is my nightmare i would be i would
i would pay to see that movie like and
it was totally serious oh i don't think
i could i would take money to watch it
do you watch movies much these days no
no i took my kids to see top gun too and
they love that but would you give it on
a scale from one to ten
compared to what like what's the scale
the best movie of all time i don't know
or what did you expect of it
jones maybe it's it's much better than i
thought it would be
um i didn't think it was that good but
compared to like other moves yeah like
it's like recent movies last few years
yeah it's fantastic it was impressive
that he flew the plane himself tom tom
cruise from what i've heard he was
actually piloting
he does do a lot of zone stunts and he
has his pilot's
license that not come from i kind of
doubt it i don't know i thought that he
was piloting i mean certain scenes i
don't feel like i'm not sure hold on
like because they're flying the f-14s
the two-seaters they're shooting him
from the front so how the hell is he
flying the plane then
i don't think i don't know i don't know
i heard that maybe that's not true i
should dig into it all right let's read
some more we got jay chacha says the
female who got stomped at the t-mobile
in arizona with no one to help her
horrible security oh yeah no right yeah
with her know how you saw that she's
like the guy walks in and then he goes
uh could you and then wham yeah
and then just starts wailing the [ __ ]
out of her this is why that dude in
vegas like nope
not gonna try and wait to find out and i
bet if it goes to trial he's gonna be
like the lawyer's gonna be like here's
500 videos showing exactly what happens
to these people he watched these twitter
feeds all day
and stop asian hate yeah totally your
honor there were people marching in
every major city talking about how asian
people were being targeted this guy in a
ski mask jumps the the counter not going
to wait to find out yep not going to
wait to be the statistic huh
all right
mikcila says wealthy philanthro
philanthropists should spend every last
cent of their fortune and effort to get
a convention of states repeal the 19th
hahahaha
the 19th i'd say the 17th
yeah what yeah what do you think about
the 19th are you uh are you one of those
what do you mean i mean well that's like
a long conversation
i don't know the 19th amendment granted
women the right to vote
okay the thing is
if i could give up my right to vote to a
husband who i trusted and thought would
make better decisions and it would
guarantee something better i would be
open to it right i don't
think that
feminism
was necessarily the best thing for this
country especially third wave feminism
but generally
no offense to all of you but if you're
willing to make a tenth fast and furious
like no i have to vote for myself i
can't trust your judgment never trust me
you're wrong to do it for you you just
exemplified exactly why we have to
repeal the 19th so we can get a 10th
fact i think there are 10 fans they're
worrying on the 10th so it we'll do get
out over the 11th
uh confirmed top tom cruise did they did
like a boot camp three-month navy
approved boot camp training course for
him and his co-stars to learn to fly i
guess they were flying huh all right
there you go he's had his pilot's
license since 1994. that's impressive to
me i thought you were going to confirm
how many fast and the furious movies
well dude listen confirm fast i mean we
all used to make fun of tom cruise and
now it's like oh it turns out he was
totally right about anti-depressants oh
man did you see that clip now it's
recirculating where he was talking to
matt lauer and he's like dude the
psychiatric industry is for pro i don't
know if you're saying it's for profit
but you're showing like this and that
was incredible i remember how they made
him look crazy when he was like oh he's
a scientologist he's crazy he thinks you
can kill yourself are crazy about a lot
of things they're just right about that
that was fascinating yeah
all right kyler shebs says do you think
new yorkers will start eating each other
or the rats first rats
well probably all happen at once i don't
know man i'd rather i'd rather eat a
person than a rat yeah i think so too
if those are the options and it's like
okay well
i i'd rather choose neither but
plus like where's the major rat hunting
ground the subway and you have to go
down there and do you know what's gonna
be the subway at the point that we're
considering if you see rats eating a
body a human body would you eat the
human body or the rats
but they're gonna run as soon as you
approach the body
you can find a piece that they haven't
been nibbling on i'm with you scavenging
no it's so strange either or games i
know right friday night how about lambs
and how can we eat those instead
do you guys slaughter on the farm yeah
all right sparky says real mdma is
awesome mostly fake stuff out there
really yes he's right
yeah a lot of times they'll call it
ecstasy yeah like if you're doing a club
it's probably not empty mayor's cut with
a lot of things like i go to guys who
get very very good stuff and it's
methamphetamines it's methyl and
dioxymethamphetamine is what that stands
for i have not met a lot of people who
know the chemical signature name for it
yeah
all right mike gibson says i drive for a
food warehouse that supplies groceries
to major distribution centers they are
jammed full i think u.s food shortages
are going to be inconveniences not the
zombie apocalypse
this i think he's right this fall we had
a bumper week harvest uh north dakota
and some other places like i was worried
this winter was going to be bad
but
there no doubt that i've already
happened worldwide sri lanka
ecuador uh uh where a couple of ghana
like so they're they're coming they're
already here and there's going to be a
lot more the only question is how bad
does it get in america right
um he's he's right short term
all right
zenobia x says you all mentioned
transhumanism often enough i have to ask
if any of you can give a definition for
it that doesn't include people with
tubes in their in their ears prosthetics
or pacemakers
is trans humanism
that's not really the definition of it
like that's all stuff you can get now
like old people have but that's what
their point is their point is that
transhumanism is here it's kind of a
vague term because you could say that
because we have a phone that people are
cyberizing but i think like uh
you know electromagnet like like the
neural net would be an idea of a piece
of transhumanist technology i think
transhumanism is
look we're gonna have our we're gonna be
neural linked and we're gonna be talking
about how trans humanism is coming like
their point is is excellent people have
pacemakers already people have insulin
pumps
like humans are cyborgs i always thought
transhumanism was really ultimately the
goal was to be uploaded into the digital
sphere yeah ray kurzweil talks about the
singularity and ems and all that stuff
emulations and all that that's one form
of it yeah it's a vague term
transhumanism means a lot of uh it just
means that we've become more than homo
sapien we're evolving to another species
and we're probably going to evolve to
multiple species at once that branch out
robot people who live in the and then
one of them will try and kill all the
other ones because humans have been
obsessively racist over throughout the
history of because you play video games
at all uh some of them have you played
uh the new horizon for ben west no no i
played videos on little kids so we feel
like mario kart and stuff did you play
it yet i haven't played horizon so uh
spoiler alert i mean the game's been out
for a while now but the the ending is
basically
you know the original story is like
humanity gets wiped out by
self-replicating robots
then there's the zero dawn project which
once all the biomass is destroyed these
machines underground kick on that humans
built to start recreating and
re-terraforming the planet
and then in this new the second game
there's uh humans another another um
operation to save humanity was the
zenith project i think was called zenith
and they escape earth
so these people are super advanced
immortal can float and they have
advanced technology they come back to
earth and then it turns out they were
actually fleeing from
they uploaded their consciousness
replicating themselves and then freaked
out when they saw what it was and
imprisoned it enraging the
multi-consciousness of all of their
minds which escapes and then seeks to
destroy them
so anyway that's fine tim you didn't ask
me if i play horizon i don't understand
i looked around and said you guys play
it have you played horizon absolutely
not sorry what's your favorite game
well the thing is i have an older
brother so i spent a lot of time sitting
next to someone playing video games and
who was like shut up you we're not you
can't play stop
uh but we did a lot of assassins creed
when i was younger
i just figured because you didn't watch
fast and furious you probably just had
bad taste in games
tasting long says nothing
ken long says love the tim cast irl
podcast i relate to everyone on the show
including guests you guys take me back
to my 70s thank you yes well all right
the 70s or his 70s to my 70s
[Music]
all right ugly swan says to my dearest
ian we should chat sometime i love your
hungry mind i think eu theory is showing
itself uh showing itself culture
uh the eagle eats the serpent jupiter
strikes mars
[Music]
interesting some wild uh
wild information right there dr doctor
says tim just referenced ssbsts dude is
definitely a cky fan well of course if
you know how old i am you know that i
watched cky when i was what's that uh
it's it was banmar jarrah the cky was
the band then he made a video where it
was them engaging in shenanigans some
skateboarding some pushing people before
jackass yeah oh and then they made cky2k
which was a huge
viral all the skate shops had it
all right
tx pack rat says texas pack red prepping
isn't just about storing food and having
guns
get hand wood working tools a metal
lathe and a mill if a part breaks on my
gun i can make it no store needed
he's there you know yeah
i didn't talk about everything but he's
not community i like how you emphasize
how prepping it also means prepare your
community probably the most important
part is community definitely it
definitely is
all right ugly swan says damn you
brought up magic the gathering i have to
comment ian how do you play magic do you
thirst for war
i brought my bruna back out and i'm
loving it uh i'm pretty utilitarian if
i'm playing against someone that has a
deck that's going to go infinite i'll
kill them as fast as possible if that's
talking about me about if tim plays blue
he's a ton
but i like trickery and i like to watch
what they do and then respond to the
enemy usually all my decks are blue yeah
tim plays pretty nasty dick it's also
not paid to win
i know that's what i was thinking about
right artifact decks that are trained to
win on turn four you have no choice you
have to just be making up words right
now we would never know oh we should
play magic it's great right now let's do
it bust them out yeah we bought we
bought a whole bunch of this that's
right i've never played it's great yeah
yeah but you but you know what it is i
understand the game i just don't know
anything about it yeah i love i love
burn you know if it's if you can sustain
it
yeah we did we did a draft and i put
together an aggro deck and it it fell
victim to all of the
ian basically had a midnight or
something mid-range well i couldn't get
enough damage in before he got his you
know creatures out and then that's how
you lose with aggro he got me i like
drawing cards a lot too cards like decks
where i do like 35 things in one turn i
love that stuff all right gu knight says
tim what are your thoughts on adding a
message board to the site it would be a
good place for members to talk about
news current events and link sources a
good way to check the pulse of your fans
yes so the one thing is we're we've been
we've been trying to develop a new
commenting system
and um we're trying to do it in a way
that promotes
other uh social social platforms because
like i don't say too much but how
facebook has the you know most websites
that have comments we'll just like put a
facebook comment thing on it you can
embed it
so we want to do something like that
with a different platform we might just
put back on the original um comments
and uh
we were thinking about doing some kind
of messaging system for for members so
that there's a community building thing
happening but uh the issue is we have
like one developer and so it's it's an
issue of how much we can afford and how
fast we can do it but yeah first i was
like screw facebook but at the same time
it's like some comments are better than
no comments so it might be worth it as a
stepping stone and if we did facebook
comments you snap your fingers and
they're there it's like really easy to
generate and then it posts on facebook
and people can share on facebook so but
facebook is awful
all right waffle sense he says tim you
all run commander right what commanders
do you run my omnath
locus
locus of mana will destroy you and to
the viewers teach your kids magic
because they won't be able to afford
drugs yes magic the gathering is an
expensive game that's what he was saying
pay to win yeah but i mean honestly you
could just download pieces of paper that
have the images on them cut them up put
some cardboard on it and play you don't
actually need proxies if you really want
to play not not you can't do it in
tournaments but you know typically we're
playing at home make the deck you want
to make to play the best dude i don't
think your omnoth deck can beat tim's
kiki cheeky deck i mean that thing is
like a netdeck just built to slay it's
like it's golden yeah cards are gold
all the cards are foil except for the
ones that are like alpha and beta that's
awesome it's a really insanely expensive
deck kai car that one's also kind of
ridiculous that's my favorite deck red
white and blue red white and blue baby
america
then your other one is thousand of the
deep
oh that one's that's ridiculous it's
just dude you should play tim sometime
it's not funny
it's not fun
yeah it's not
no no we i mean it's fun if you like
just like
the gag is asked games ian and i got to
the point where we just roll a dime
whoever got the highest rebecca good
game because whoever goes first wins
whoever gets the man a [ __ ] first yeah i
mean it just whoever goes first man
all right howard says trump's an actor
dero contracts
o x r p to get you by what i don't know
what that means
all right let's see
tim wallace says done into the show ian
some love
donating to show ian some love man gets
too much hate here
really
i feel like i could have hated on you
way more yeah great conversation i'll
say stuff i think that provokes people's
you know insecurities sometimes yeah
and i just better to be honest than the
uh i'm with you receive
garhant says trump level 12 bard college
of lore strength 11 dexterity 8
constitution 14 intelligent 16 wisdom 8
charisma 20
favorite attack
cutting words weaknesses cream-filled
lard burgers fix your pitch's email if
you want to dm we have disabled the
pitch's email yeah we had to that was a
great description though yeah
yeah yeah definitely
beastly devil says tim you son of a gun
you kept bringing up battlestar
galactica and decided to watch it best
decision i have made and one of my
favorite sci-fi shows now adama senior
is is is my character and a great leader
so say we all
dude that's the old school battle star
new one well i don't know the old school
one was better in the 70s yeah i've seen
it that's good you know what's what's
crazy is so you know the i'm assuming
the stories are very similar or you've
seen the new the new one no
so the cylons destroy the the colonies
and then the fleet is just traveling and
all they have left are these fleet of
ships
and then there's one plot where there's
a ship that's just mining effectively
coal like so it's all of these people
have to work 16 hour days with no breaks
and they're just slaves
and they're like if you stop working we
all die
and so then there's a revolt and then
they're like other people have to rotate
in because they're going to just kill
themselves or something the show's
brutal
yeah crazy and then in the end they make
it to earth and then they're like the
people on earth are compatible with us
it's like okay
that's like a weird plot point but i
guess
all right chris van doome durham
tim and ian have you heard of the
trading card game flesh and blood i'd
quit competitive magic the gathering
after 15 years for this game it's
amazing you'll both love it we'll take a
look we actually have a card game in
development right now
um about uh culture war politics and
stuff being developed yeah i was where i
built the tim and i built the uh the
database and sheamus did the art freedom
tunes just did the art but now we do
have like a game master who's
combing through it and setting it up and
fixing game testing yeah
all right marshall mello says chris's
opinion piece yesterday was one of the
most unintelligent and disgusting things
i've ever read somebody needs to check
his mental health seriously wow outraged
i think chris wrote that he was
pro-choice pro-abortion yeah he said it
the headline is something like i
i i'm
because i believe in the bible i'm a
pro-choice or pro-abortion uh i have to
say chris carr is like the backbone of
all of my work so he can write whatever
opinion piece he wants i mean he's uh
he's a very intelligent guy and so i'm
i'm marshall i'm glad you read it i'm
glad you've expressed your opinion
disliking it because that's a good thing
and i'm glad chris wrote it yeah if it
makes you think it's worth being there i
mean that's the the point of effective
op-ed pieces right and then mark
marshall for for your thoughts it should
arm you against this is the thing like
read people you disagree with express
your disagreement and now you're better
equipped to argue your ideas that's what
i'm all about
so
that's a good thing
all right sparky says star trek the
original series is the only good star
trek
next generation
next generation
uh what about what about you original
series
i mean
i thought like it depends so if we're
talking about captains i mean kirk far
and away better than some [ __ ]
frenchmen right
but if you're talking about overall
series i can see i can see the argument
for next generation yeah they had they
had the opportunity to improve upon it
yeah yeah it was there were a lot of
elements that were better what do you
think now do you watch the orville no
i'm actually really impressed with seth
macfarlane he did a whole episode about
de-transitioning kids that were forced
to transition and like
they like spoiler alert i guess for
those that don't want to hear it because
it was like a couple weeks ago but they
did an episode where one of the planets
in the union was ejected
because they were force forcing kids to
transition it's like it's a crazy cra
i'm like i can't believe he wrote this
stuff
but like as long as he's willing to
write these stories maybe some of these
people who follow him because he's very
democrat might actually
be exposed some other ideas basically
the plot was on their planet they don't
allow women they force transition them
to mail and then this kid grows up and
is like this is not what i'm supposed to
be and then there's like a conflict with
the traditions of the planet that want
to transition kids the kid
de-transitions and then the planet is
trying to stop like their smugglers
rescuing these kids from being forced to
go undergo sex changes yeah it's crazy
that he wrote this story and then
they've done it two episodes on it yeah
yeah but i can promise you uh
i'm i could totally be wrong i'm betting
that that that's his vision of like the
the smugglers with the blue states and
the planets the red states i don't you
know
some people have said like
he's trying to make a story about why
kids should transition but i'm like i
don't know about what you think he's
thinking all i know is he did a show
where they forcefully transition a baby
seth macfarlane literally says
you can't perform a section in a baby
that's unethical
and then they they've got
several episodes now where they're
trying to stop
minors from undergoing sex changes so
i'm like all right
like you'd think you'd be canceled
heavily for for getting into that
territory
my friends if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you do like it become a member at
timcast.com to support our work it is
the weekend tomorrow ian and i carter
several other people including adrian
norman pete peratta uh we are going to
be filming a music video i'm really
really excited for this it's gonna be
really really cool so that'll be a lot
of fun uh you follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at timcast uh
tucker you wanna show anything out no
nothing you got social media
i mean you can tuckermax.com or whatever
i'm on social but yeah
right on man thanks for thanks for
hanging out thanks for having me yeah
i'm hannah claire you can find me on
instagram at hannah claire.b and you can
find me of course on timcast.com with
chris carr the controversial opinion
writer and executive editor follow me at
ian crossland.net get through my socials
from there hit me up anywhere on any
network and i was on pop culture crisis
earlier today if you haven't seen the
episode yet you can watch it on youtube
at pop culture crisis tucker it's really
good to meet you man that was really
pretty found something especially just
talking about the mdma and like
psychological therapy i think it's a
huge part of the story moving forward
thanks for coming man yeah my pleasure
bye everyone
and chris is here thanks for watching
uh check out other shows pop culture
crisis
and uh we'll be back monday with uh with
another episode we got i just want to
say this
monday is going to be one of the best
episodes we've ever had i'm super
excited for who's coming we don't really
don't announce the guest actually i want
to jinx it but you guys are going to be
so excited i am honored is an honor and
a privilege so just stay tuned for
monday and we'll see you all then
you